THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WILL
COME TO ORDER- GOOD MORNING AS
WE CONTINUE TO TAKE PRECAUTIONS
TO MANAGER ON GOING COVERT
NINETEEN REST THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
IN ITS PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON AND TELECONFERENCE
BURKE DISSIPATION FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163. 877-226-8163 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN SIX
TWO. TWO FOUR SIX TWO I WILL
REPEAT THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN
SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX TWO
OBVIOUSLY ARE MAINTAINED TO
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MABREY REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WE'RE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING IN THE-
STREET BUILDING AND OBVIOUSLY WE
WANT MEMBERS TO COME ON DOWN TO
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED BECAUSE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A CAR. SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
OUR CORPSMAN BEGIN ARE HERE
UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT NOW WE DON'T
HAVE ACQUIREMENT SO WE'RE GONNA
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE SO IN
THAT CASE- WE'RE GONNA TAKE
TESTIMONY ON OUR BILLS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD- AND THEN WILL HAVE
ACTION ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM IN
ORDER TO MAKE OUR ACTIONS-
CORTINA OIL- SO BEFORE WE TAKE
OUR OUR VOTE WE'RE JUST TRYING
TO MAKE THAT ANNOUNCEMENT.
THERE'S NO POINT TO TAKE A ROLL
CALL AT THIS POINT BECAUSE WE'RE
GOING TO BE- SUBCOMMITTEE SO
WE'RE GONNA MOVE RIGHT TO THE
BUSINESS OF THE DAY DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS OF INSTITUTING A
TIME LIMIT ON WITNESS TESTIMONY
EACH SIDE WILL BE A OUR- EQUAL
AMOUNT. TIME FOR PRIMARY
TESTIMONY ALL OTHERS WISHING O
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. ON THE
MEASURE. SO AGAIN ONLY THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES GET TO GIVE
SPEECHES. EVERYBODY ELSE HAS TO
DO NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION- ALSO WE'RE HERE IN A
FISCAL COMMITTEE SO I WOULD HOPE
YOU ALL RESTRAINED FROM RE
LITIGATING THE POLICY. MERITS OR
LACK OF MERITS THAT YOU SEE IN A
BILL THIS IS NOT. WE'RE NOT HERE
TO NEGOTIATE FOR TO HEAR THE
POLICY IMPLICATIONS WERE HERE TO
STRICTLY FOCUS. ON THE FISCAL
IMPACTS OF THE BILL SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT TO EVERYBODY
OUT THERE- SO WE HAVE A SPECIAL
ORDER OF BUSINESS OUR FIRST BILL
IS SB THREE THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT. BY CENTER- BURKE ON-
COMMITTEE ASSISTANCE RECOVERY
EMPOWERMENT CARE COURT PROGRAM.
IT IS A SPECIAL ORDER BUSINESS-
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHOR HAS WAY PRESENTATION AS
HAVE ALL THE AUTHORS TODAY SO
EVERY AUTHOR. THAT HAS WHAT WE
HAVE A HUNDRED AND SOME ODD
BILLS ALL OF THE AUTHORS OF WAY
PRESENTATION ON THEIR BILLS- SO
WE HAVE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- AND- SO WE'RE GONNA GO
RIGHT TO SUPPORT TESTIMONY BY
THE WAY I'M GONNA GIVE. THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES ON THE
OPPOSITION SIDE TOTAL OF FIVE
MINUTES THAT'S A TOTAL OF FIVE
MINUTES AND THEN WE WILL HAVE A
TOTAL OF- TWELVE MINUTES AFTER
THAT FOR THE ME TOO SAID WILL
GIVE BOTH SIDES. THE OPPORTUNITY
AND SO THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SO IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM WHO WANTS TO
SUPPORT. SB. THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT. SEEING NO RUSH TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR IF YOU GO
TO THE PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT OF
S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT ONE OPPRESSED ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN IT'S ONE
ZERO. GIVE ME A MOMENT HERE.
AND WE CAN GO FIRST TO LINE
FORTY FOUR BEFORE HAD. I WOULD
IDEA YOUR YOUR OFFER YOU'RE GOOD
ENOUGH. OKAY SB HERE WELL
USUALLY YOU'RE ACTUALLY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOUR LIVE. HERE WE
ARE IN STUDIO TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
AND YOU ARE LIVE. NUMBER FORTY
FOUR YOU CAN GO. BUT THE PART I
DON'T KNOW IF WE AT. I'M CALLING
TO OCCUR AT DELL OKAY WE'RE ON
SUPPORT RIGHT NOW. YES SO WE'LL
QUEUE YOU UP WHEN WE GET TO
OPPOSITION. WE ARE ON SUPPORT OF
S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT AND
WHEN THE MODERATOR CALLS ON YOU
YOU START TO TALK. IT WILL NOW
GO TO LINE THIRTY NINE. I AM OF
THE LOS ANGELES BUSINESS COUNCIL
COMING INTO PORT THANK YOU.
TEXTBOOK. NINE THIRTY. HI I'M
RITA KANYA I AM A MOM OF THE
SEMESTER FOR SOME SPECIFIC
SCHIZOPHRENIA I'M HERE TO CALL
IN FOR SUPPORT I DON'T SEE IT AS
A VIOLATION OF MY THANK YOU THE
NEXT ROLE LINE TWENTY. YES THANK
YOU MY NAME IS ALEX STUBER I
HAVE A SON WHO- YEAH SAY YOU
KNOW SAYS I AM SUPPORTING THIS
BILL. JUDGE MANLEY SCORED IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IS BEING THE
ONLY TIME THE LIFE THANK YOU
SIR. THE BOOK. AND CURRENTLY NOT
TRIGGERING QUEUE ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN OUR SUPPORT NOW WE WILL GO
WE HAVE I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
THREE LEAD WITNESSES OUR PRIMARY
WITNESS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION- WE HAVE KAREN THE
CARI ON BEHALF OF MENTAL HEALTH
AMERICA CALIFORNIA ERIC HARRIS
ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS.
AND THEN WE HAVE SOMEBODY-
MICHELLE CABRERA FROM THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ASSOCIATION
WHO ALL EXPRESSED CONCERNS. THE
THREE OF YOU HAVE A TOTAL OF
FIVE MINUTES I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
SPOKEN AMONGST YOURSELVES TO
KAREN BUKHARI ON BEHALF OF
MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA AND OU
CAN PROCEED. THANK YOU CHAIR
KAREN TO CARRY MENTAL HEALTH
AMERICA OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH EMPOWERMENT
NETWORK. MY SISTER JENNIFER
LIVES WITH SMI S. U. D. AND IS
OVER TWENTY YEARS HOMELESS I
HAVE SEEN THE EFFECTS ON HER OF
THE EXTREME TRAUMA SHE HASN'T
TOWARD OVERTIME. THIS TRAUMA
LEADS TO FEAR OF THE SYSTEM
WHICH MAKES PEOPLE LIKE HER VERY
DIFFICULT AND VERY COSTLY TO
SERVE. REQUIRING JENNIFER TO
ATTEND COURT BECAUSE OF A MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITION WILL ONLY
EXACERBATE HER TRAUMA AND CAUSE
HER TO RUN. THE LAST TIME SHE
WAS IN TREATMENT SHE STARTED OUT
EXCITED BUT WITHIN THREE WEEKS
AS SHE BEGAN TO WORK THROUGH HER
TRAUMA SHE COULDN'T HANDLE IT
AND SHE LEFT THE PROGRAM. THAT
WAS ALMOST THREE YEARS AGO AND I
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM HER SINCE.
JENNIFER REALLY WANTS SERVICES
BUT THIS IS NOT THE RIGHT
PROGRAM FOR PEOPLE LIKE HER
MONEY WILL BE WASTED AND THE
TARGET POPULATION WILL NOT BE
HELPED. CARE COURT WILL REQUIRE
MUCH MORE STATE FUNDING THAN THE
MAY REVISE ADDRESSES. INCLUDING
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS FOR
DIVERSE HOUSING. FUNDING FOR
COMPREHENSIVE MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE SERVICES AND
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC DEFENDERS. SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT INCLUDES
THE GUARANTEE OF HOUSING THE
CYCLE OF HOMLESSNESS CRISIS AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS WILL NOT BE
BROKEN UNTIL CALIFORNIA INVEST
INVOLUNTARY COMPREHENSIVE
SERVICES. WITH PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. NOT ONLY
WILL CARE COURT NOT WORK FOR
LIKE MY SISTER IT WILL BE A
COSTLY MISTAKE FOR CALIFORNIA. I
URGE YOU TO VOTE KNOWING CARE
COURT AND TAKE THE TIME TO
DEVELOP AN EFFECTIVE COST
EFFECTIVE AND MEANINGFUL
SOLUTION WITHOUT PEOPLE LIKE
JENNIFER THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GO TO OUR NEXT WITNESS ERIC
HARRIS. GOOD MORNING SHARE MY
NAME IS AIR CARRIERS AND I AM
THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY AT
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA I
HAVE A PHYSICAL DISABILITY AND
HAVE SEVERAL FAMILY MEMBERS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH DISABILITIES
INCLUDING ONE SPECIFICALLY WHO
HAS BEEN INSTITUTIONALIZED AND
ALMOST. THE R. C. IS PART OF A
COALITION WITH MORE THAN FIFTY
ORGANIZATIONS IN COMPLETE
OPPOSITION TO S. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT. KERA COURT IS A
COMPLETE VIOLATION OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS HUMAN RIGHTS AND IS A
RACIAL JUSTICE ISSUE THAT WILL
HARM BLACK IN LINE NEXT PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS AT A
DISPROPORTIONATE RATE. WE KNOW
THE BLACK PEOPLE ESPECIALLY ARE
MISDIAGNOSED WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
AND ARE NOT GIVEN ADEQUATE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IF THEY
NEED THEM. OUR HOUSE PEOPLE WILL
BE TARGETED SO IT'S LIKELY MORE
MANY MORE PEOPLE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BLACK
INDIGENOUS AND OTHER PEOPLE OF
COLOR WILL BE SWEPT UP WHICH IS
A WASTE OF RESOURCES AND WILL
CAUSE MORE HARM THAN GOOD.
ALTHOUGH THE BILL ANALYSIS
ESTIMATES THAT 700-021-2000
PEOPLE COULD BE INCLUDED IN CARE
COURT. THAT COULD BE SERVED A
SEVERELY LOW ESTIMATE WITH
ANNUAL COST IN THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO ACCOUNT
FOR TREATMENT COURT COSTS
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING STAFF AND
ADDITIONAL SERVICES. WE HAVE
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON HOUSING
CALIFORNIA ANY NUMBER OF THEM
COULD BE EXPERIENCING VARIOUS
DISABILITIES AND TRAUMA AT ANY
TIME. THE POLICY AND COST OF S.
B. THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT COULD
BE ASTRONOMICAL BASED ON OUR
RESEARCH AND THE WORK OF
ORGANIZATIONS WITH YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. THE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
FOR THIS FRAMEWORK OF THE BILL
IS HALF BAKED AT BEST AND COULD
BE A DISASTER WORSE. THE STATE
HAS DONE A GREAT JOB SAVING AND
HAS AN ESTIMATED SURPLUS OF
NINETY EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
CALIFORNIA CAN NOT GO BACKWARDS
BY TAKING ON A FRAMEWORK THAT
CREATES AN UNKNOWN BURDEN ON THE
STATE. YOUR ADVOCATES HOUSING
ADVOCATES AND OTHERS BELIEVE
THAT HAVE BETTER MENTAL HEALTH
STRATEGY SHOULD BE DEVELOPED FOR
NEXT YEAR. THANK YOU AND I URGE
A NO VOTE ON SB THIRTEEN THIRTY.
THANKS VERY MUCH MISTER HARRISON
WE HAVE MICHELLE CABRERA. NOT
SURE IF SHE'S HERE IN PERSON
THANK. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS MICHELLE KEPT IT UP WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS BELIEVE THAT WE
WILL INCUR SIGNIFICANT NEW COSTS
WHICH THE STATE WILL BE
OBLIGATED TO REIMBURSE AS A
RESULT OF SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT. THESE INCLUDE SIGNIFICANT
COSTS OUTSIDE OF MEDICAL
SERVICES CURRENTLY COVERED
THROUGH THE STATE'S REALIGNMENT
DEAL WITH COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH BASED ON OUR ESTIMATES WE
BELIEVE THE STATE LINKER NEW
MANDATE AND RIVER REIMBURSEMENT
REQUIREMENTS IN THE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OR MORE FOR
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS HOURS OF TIME
SPENT IN COURT AS WELL AS
PERFORMING OUTREACH AND
ENGAGEMENT. THAT IS TIME SPENT
LOOKING FOR RESPONDENTS IN THE
COMMUNITY AND ATTEMPTING TO
CONVINCE THEM TO WORK WITH US AT
EVERY STEP OF THE PROCESS FROM
THE SETTLEMENT TO EVALUATION TO
DEVELOPMENT OF THE TREATMENT
PLAN AND ONGOING ENGAGEMENT AND
SERVICES. NON MEDICAL
TRANSPORTATION TO AND FROM THE
COURT AND OTHER NON MEDICAL
APPOINTMENTS SERVICES ORDERED BY
pTHROUGH PRIVATE INSURANCE OR
MEDICAL INSURANCE TIME SPENT
ENGAGING INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR
HOUSING PLANT AND COORDINATION
OF HOUSING WITH THOSE HOUSING
PROVIDERS. TIME SPENT ENGAGING
AND SERVING INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
PRIVATELY INSURED AND SEEKING
REIMBURSEMENT FROM THEIR
INSURANCE IN TO MEET WITH COURTS
ON REFERRALS EVALUATION
SETTLEMENTS AND ONGOING
HEARINGS. AND THE TIGHT
TIMELINES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BILL WILL REQUIRE HIGHER THAN
NORMAL STAFFING LEVELS IN TERMS
OF THE IMPACTED POPULATIONS CBH
DA BELIEVES THAT REFERRAL SECURE
PORT WILL RANGE IN THE HIGH TENS
OF THOUSANDS TO LOW HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS. AS WE
BELIEVE THAT THE INITIAL
INTERESTING USING CARE COURT- TO
ADDRESS THE BROADER HOW ISSUE OR
THE- IN ABILITY OF PEOPLE WITH
PRIVATE INSURANCE TO ACCESS
ADEQUATE COVERAGE WILL FAR
EXCEED THE TARGET. RANGE A CITED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
PROCESSING THESE REFERRALS ALONE
WILL REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT COUNTY
STAFF TIME WORKLOAD CAN CLICK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HEARING OUR
CONCERNS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THIS ROOM I'M GOING TO START
THE CLOCK ON WE HAVE TWELVE
MINUTES OF. TIME IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO OFFER ME
TO TESTIMONY AT THIS MOMENT
WHICH IS YOUR NAME JUST COME UP
TO THE MICROPHONE LINEUP. YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION YEAH COMMITTEE CHAIR
MEMBERS MATTHEW GALLAGHER
COWBOYS IS ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
YOU. AFTERNOON RECOVERY CENTER
PERSONAL CHAIN CRYSTAL UNITED
CONSUMER MOVEMENT ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. ANYONE ELSE SEEING NO ONE
ELSE COME IN THE MIKE FROM
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP
THE OPPOSITION. TO SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT NOW IS THE TIME.
THANK YOU AGAIN IT IS ONE ZERO.
AND WILL FIRST GO TO LIKE FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
RICHARD GALLO VOLUNTARY COWBOYS
SUSAN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND
OPPOSITION AS A PERSON WILL LIFT
SPIRITS AND A FULL MONTH
HEALTHCARE WORKER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. EXTRALITE FIFTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING GOING BACK IF FOR
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
OPPOSITION. EXTROVERT ONLINE.
SIXTY ONE. THE MORNING CAROL
GRIFFIN FROM BEFORE THE SELF
PUBLISHED DEFENDER'S OFFICE
CALLING US. SIX FOUR. BROADCOM
OF THE TOWN OF HOW WITH A
CONCERN POSITION. AND. THIRTY
VIDEO ME ROMERO WITH IT HOW
BEHAVIORAL PLANNING COUNCIL WITH
A FULL AND LET THEM. EIGHT FORTY
THREE. GOOD MORNING TYLER BEYOND
OF THE COUNT SAFETY O'CLOCK AND
DRUG PROGRAM MADE AND CALIFORNIA
LINE HOW CAN WE SERVICE WITH THE
CONCERN THAT SHOULD THANK YOU.
LIFE FOR KEY. HE WAY PEARL
PATTERSON WITH THE CURE
CONNECTION I'M A PERSON WITH
LIVED EXPERIENCE AYE OPPOSED.
AND THE HELP IN PERSON. THANK
LINE FORTY SEVEN. YOUR AVAILABLE
BILL WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. LEVINE.
TWELVE I TWELFTH. LAURA
ROSENBERGER HARDER AND POSET
FELL FROM FRESNO. THANK YOU LINE. SIXTY ALSO INTRODUCTION
BIPOLAR SUPPORT ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIANS STRONGLY OPPOSE.
LINE. SIXTY SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS
ALLEY WHAT I LIVE IN SACRAMENTO
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THAT SPELL
. BLIND. TWENTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING ANNA LIVIA AND PLAYING
WITH HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH AMEREN
SCOTT PHYSICIAN. LINE. FORTY
SIX. GOOD MORNING GOOD MILLS
CARE FOR CALIFORNIA CALITION IN
OPPOSITION SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
JENNIFER THE DEADLINE MY FAVOR
NAMES. GIVEN HONOR OKAY MY
FAVORITE AND MY DAUGHTER MIDDLE
NAME CURSOR ONE MANY CATHOLIC
WITH CALVET AND WE ARRANGED
OPPOSITION. LINE FIFTY THREE.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS MICHELLE
THE SAKE OF FROM TRANSFORMING
JUSTICE ORANGE COUNTY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. LINE FIFTY SIX. HI
THIS IS JENNIFER HANA THANK YOU
FOR GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
SHARE MY SUPPORT AS A FAMILY
MEMBER OF THE SERIOUSLY MENTALLY
ILL PERSON INCARCERATED IN
PRISON SYSTEM AND NOT
REPRESENTED AT THE STAKEHOLDER
IN ANY OF THE DISABILITY RIGHTS
GROUPS THAT ARE BEING
REPRESENTED TODAY I'M AND TRONG
. SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
LIVES OF THE SERIOUSLY MENTALLY
ILL LIKE MY SON TO BE DISCARDED
THANK YOU THE GARBAGE WASTE BIN
OF THE- THANK YOU. IT'S FINE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING CHAU NGUYEN WITH
DIGNITY AND POWER NOW AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. SINGLE LINE
NINETEEN. HELLO BORROW WITH OF
THE POOR CONNECTION BOTH.
NETSCOUT LINE ELEVEN. HE'S YEAH
YES AT GO AHEAD GO HEAD. ONE
THING THAT WOULD HELP FOLKS WITH
WHEN YOU GET QUEUED UP IF YOU
TURN OFF THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING US ON WILL GET LESS
FEEDBACK AND WILL BE BLE TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY SO PLEASE TURN
OFF THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THIS ON AND THEN JUST SPEAK INTO
YOUR PHONE AND WE'LL HEAR YOU
CLEARLY SO GO AHEAD. PETE LEVIN
YOU'RE STILL OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS MARK KERMODE EARNED PLAYING
WITH PATRICK MCCANN COULD
SUPPORT NETWORK I'M NOT I AM NOT
. I AM. ONLY A TO THIS BILL. HE
LIVE. SIX- APOLOGIES HONORABLE
CARRY MEMBERS AND LATER SUPPORT
LINE DANNY OFFER WITH THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS ALSO CALIFORNIANS ORDER
THANKS. LINE THIRTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS ENTRANCE
CRISTINA PONCE DE LEON WITH
SAMBAR TO DINO FREEDOM ALL AND
PROJECT AMIGA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. IN LINE
FORTY EIGHT. RAMOS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MEMBERS OF THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY ROUTE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND ENCOURAGE COUNTY
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY IS WRONGLY
OPPOSE. WE HAVE A COUPLE A
COUPLE MORE HERE IF GIVE ME JUST
A MOMENT TO GO AHEAD AND LINE
NUMBER. ALIGNED AT IF I HAD.
MISTER KAREN MEMBERS STILL BE AT
THE LEAST SHARM THE CAPITAL CITY
OF SANTA MONICA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. CONNECTIVE LINE.
EIGHTY ONE. THIRTY CAD ON BEHALF
OF THE RULE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
WITH CONCERN THANK YOU. MORE
HERE. WE LIVE. SEVENTY SEVEN. HI
MY NAME IS JUSTIN AND KELLY AND
WITH FOOD AND WATER WATCH AND
I'M LATE- TO SUPPORT. AND THEN
FURTHER AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE TAKEN THE SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. S. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT- WE STILL DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE IS NOT PARTICIPATING-
TODAY FOR ANY OF THE BILLS AND
SO WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OF THE TWO THAT ARE
HERE HAVE QUESTIONS. NO WE
THOUGHT THIS YEAR ALL RIGHT SO.
WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES SO WE'RE GONNA WAIT
TO HAVE A QUORUM THEY'LL BE NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
BILL SO THERE'S ANYONE HERE LAST
OPPORTUNITY. C. NOBODY COME
WE'VE TAKEN BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION SO WHEN WE COME BACK
WITH A QUORUM. WE WILL TAKE
ACTION ON SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT. WE'RE NOT GOING TO MOVE
TO OUR REGULAR ORDER OF BUSINESS
. THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
AND THANK EVERYBODY THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY AN IMPORTANT SUBJECT
AND IT WAS. NICE TO HEAR
EVERYBODY'S. POSITIONS WE HAVE
EIGHTY SIX BILLS ON TODAY'S
REGULAR ORDER AGENDA ALL OF THEM
ARE SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES AND
AGAIN ALL OF THE AUTHORS OF WAY
PRESENTATION. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AS I SAID IS FOR BEST
THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE FILES ON
THE BILL. AND SO WE'RE NOT GOING
TO HEAR FROM THEM TODAY- WE
STILL DON'T HAVE A QUORUM. AND
SO WILL GO RIGHT TO CONTINUE OUR
BUSINESS AS MENTIONED PRIOR TO
THE SPECIAL ORDER BUSINESS I'M-
RESERVING THE RIGHT TO INSTITUTE
A TIME LIMIT SO. AS WE PROGRESS
THROUGH OUR BILLS IT'S GOING TO
BE THREE MINUTES. TOTAL TIME FOR
EACH SIDE. AND TEN MINUTES.
THEREAFTER FOR THE ME TOO
TESTIMONY SO GOING TO THREE AND
TEN- AS A- GET A REMINDER ALL
WITNESSES SHOULD KEEP THEIR
COMMENTS TO THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS
OF THE BILL. AND REFRAIN FROM
REPEATING. ANY TESTIMONY FROM
THE POLICY COMMITTEE- AND ALSO
IF WHEN IT'S YOUR TIME TO SPEAK
MUTE THE DEVICE THAT YOU'RE
WATCHING THIS ON SO WE CAN HEAR
YOU MORE CLEARLY IF YOU DO THAT-
SO. WE ARE GOING TO OUR FIRST
ORDER OF BUSINESS WHICH I KNOW
THIS AUTHOR WELL. SB EIGHT
TWENTY NINE PORTANTINO IT'S ON
MOTION PICTURE PRODUCTION ARMORS
FIREARM SAFETY. I'VE WAY
PRESENTATION IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. WILL GO TO TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT IS THERE ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND
SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE HERE
MODERATE OR GO TO THE PHONE LINE
FOR SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT TWENTY
NINE. THE SUPPORT SB EIGHT
TWENTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY
NINE Q. ALL RIGHT WE WILL COME
BACK TO THE ROOM FOR OPPOSITION
OF SB EIGHT TWENTY NINE AS
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED SB
EIGHT TWENTY NINE. SEEING NO ONE
OPPOSE MODERATOR WILL COME BACK
TO YOU AS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB EIGHT TWENTY
NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO INFO. THE EMPLOYMENT CARE.
ONE ZERO I WILL MEXICO TO LINE
FORTY ONE BUT- HI MY NAME IS
JAMES ST I'M THE SENIOR SPECIAL
EFFECTS REPRESENTED FOR I HAVE
TO LOCAL FORTY FOUR. MAN
REVEALED THIS BILL IS REDUNDANT
AND WILL LEAD TO RUN AWAY
PRODUCTION- IN FURTHER OF THE
DIDN'T DANGEROUS BY FORCING
PRODUCTIONS TO LEAVE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WORDS FOR REGULATED.
AND CURRENTLY NONE FURTHER IN Q.
ALL RIGHT ROOF TAKE WE WILL.
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF A TWENTY NINE WE
HAVE NO QUORUM SO WHEN WE GET
BACK WE WILL. CONSIDER MOVING
THAT TO THE SUSPENSE FILE MOVING
ON SB NINE THIRTY TWO BY
PORTANTINO ON GENERAL PLAN
CIRCULATION ELEMENTS BIKE AND
PEDESTRIAN SAFETY MISTER WHITE
CASKEY. YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT
THIS WEEKEND WHEN I WAS RIDING
TO ECHO PARK IN LA I ALMOST GOT
RUN OVER TWICE. AND SO WE DO
NEED MORE BICYCLE AND PEDESTRIAN
SAFETY I'VE WAY PRESENTATION
WILL GO RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM MODERATOR OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT OF SB
NINE THIRTY TWO. TO SUPPORT SB
NINE THIRTY TO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK TO OPPOSITION OF
SB NINE THIRTY TWO IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO
NINE THIRTY TWO. SEEING NO RUSH
TO THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR WILL
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE IS OR
ANYBODY OPPOSED SB NINE THIRTY
TWO. YEAH THAT'S ONE ZERO. AND
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF NINE THIRTY TWO AND WE WILL
DISPENSE WITH IT WHEN WE GET. A
QUORUM. WILL MOVE ON THE SP TEN
SIXTY SEVEN BY PORTANTINO ON
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS PROJECT
AUTOMOBILE PARKING REQUIREMENTS.
WE WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
SIXTY SEVEN. SEEING NO RUSH TO
THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN SIXTY SEVEN. AND SUPPORT SB
CAN SIXTY SEVEN OF COURSE IT'S
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. CERTAINLY
NOBODY IN Q. I WILL COME BACK TO
THIS ROOM FOR OPPOSITION TO THE
SP TEN SIXTY SEVEN IS THERE
ANYONE OPPOSED SB TEN SIXTY
SEVEN AND TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
NOBODY'S HERE. MODERATOR WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE FOR OPPOSITION
TO TEN SIXTY SEVEN. ONE ZERO TO
OPPOSE. THANK YOU CURRENTLY ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF TEN SIXTY SEVEN
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES I'VE WAY PRESENTATION
AND WE WILL DEAL WITH THE
SUSPENSE CONSIDERATION WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM WILL MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT BILL SB ELEVEN THIRTY
SIX ALSO BY PORTANTINO ON A
SEQUEL EXPEDITED ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW FOR CLIMATE CHANGE
REGULATIONS WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT COME
ON UP RUSHING TO THE MICROPHONES
TO CHAIR MIKE MONEY GOING TO BE
HALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL AND STRONGLY SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR WILL ANYONE ELSE
NO ONE ELSE IS HERE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE
FOR SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN THIRTY
SIX. PRESS ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT
AT. ELEVEN THIRTY SIX. NINE
CURRENTLY IN Q. RIGHT WELL GOOD
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN THIRTY SIX
IS OR ANYONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED TO ELEVEN THIRTY SIX NO
ONE HAS COME TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN
THIRTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME TO OPPOSE.
CURRENTLY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION I
SEE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES SO WE'LL CLOSE THE
PUBLIC BUT ESTIMATES OF. NINE
ELEVEN BUT OPEN OKAY IS IT ALL
RIGHT WE'LL WERE CLOSING ON
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX AND WE WILL
DEAL WITH IT WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM. MOVING S. B. TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE ALSO BY PORTANTINO ON
SINGLE USE PRODUCTS WASTE
REDUCTION DISHWASHER GRANT FOR
OUR K. TWELVE SCHOOLS. I'VE WAY
PRESENTATION IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL GO TO RIGHT TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. MODERATE OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE. EACH PRESS
ONE DIRECTORS TIME TO SUPPORT.
IF YOU HEARING YOU GO FIRST TO
LINE WELL AHEAD. LAURA
ROSENBERGER HIGHER SUPPORT MR
STILL. THANK YOU. IN MEXICO PINE
TWENTY THREE. WORK HI I WAS
TRYING TO CALL IN ON THE LAST
BILL AS OPPOSITION THANK YOU WE
DON'T NEED TO SEE COOPER SLOWED
DOWN AS CONSUMERS THANK YOU WE
NEED SIEGLER THANK YOU. AND LINE
SIX EFFECT. MEMBERS JOHNSON LINE
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE HEAL THE
BAY IN SANTA MONICA WE STRONG
SUPPORTER OF TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
AM BELIEVE IT'S MONEY WELL SPENT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
CURRENT AND FURTHER IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WELL GOOD OPPOSITION AT
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED
SEEING NOBODY COME TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE. THE FIRST ONE
ZERO TWO OPPOSED. CURRENTLY
NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION AND WE
HAVE NO QUORUM SO WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM WILL DEAL WITH THAT I SEE
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
SO WE WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING AND MOVE ON TO SB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR CORTESE ON
MOTION PICTURE PRODUCTION SET
SAFETY. WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING FOR SUPPORT IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM MISSING NO
ONE COME TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE. EXPRESS WONDER AT
THIS TIME TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL CODE
OPPOSITION. MMHM OPPOSED TO SP
EIGHT THIRTY ONE THING NO ONE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. EACH
PRESS ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE. AND WE
GOT A LINE FORTY ONE IS GO AHEAD
. HELLO MY NAME IS JAMES STREET
ON THE SENIOR SPECIAL EFFECTS
REPRESENTATIVE RIGHT OUT THE
LOCAL FORTY FOUR- I'VE BEEN
THERE FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS I'VE
BEEN IN THE INDUSTRY FOR OVER
THIRTY FIVE. THIS LEGISLATION
NOT PREVENTED THE ACCIDENTS THAT
WOULD ONLY CREATE. RUNAWAY
PRODUCTION. AS UNNECESSARY
BUREAUCRACY THAT WILL COST OUR
STATE MONEY. IDEAS THE- IN THE-
POLICIES IN PLACE IF FOLLOWED
WOULD HAVE PREVENTED THE
ACCIDENT IF PEOPLE DO NOT FALL
POLICIES. THEN THERE'S NO
PREVENTING THEM FROM DOING IT.
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
LEGISLATION THANK THANK YOU.
INTERMENT AND FURTHER IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT THIRTY
ONE. AND THERE'S NO FILE AND NO
QUESTIONS TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
WE WILL DEAL WITH IT WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM MOVING ON SB NINE
NINE NINE BY SENATOR CORTESE
HEALTH COVERAGE MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
JANET SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WE DO
HAVE A LEAD WITH THIS IN SUPPORT
JANE CRYSTAL WHO IS HERE I
BELIEVE. YEAH COME ON UP JANE.
THANK YOU SENATORS- ON ENGINE
CRYSTAL WITH- AMONG THE YOUTH
AND YOUR MENTAL HEALTH ADVOCATE
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY. ON LONG
TIME THE RECOVERY MYSELF. AND
FORTY YEARS ACTUALLY. SO I WAS
DIAGNOSED FIRST QUARTER OF
COLLEGE. AND- DISCOVERED THE.
DISABILITY CARE SYSTEM SO A YEAR
AGO I I'VE I'VE EVER I'M A
WRITER AND I'VE WRITTEN TO- THE
GOVERNOR'S TOP HEALTH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT. AND
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN I RETURNED TO
ADVOCACY LAST YEAR I NOTICED
THAT OUR MENTAL HEALTH
CALIFORNIA MENTAL HEALTH
MOVEMENT HAD BEEN CO OPTED BY
BIG PHARMA. AND MY FATHER WAS
PHARMACEUTICAL SALES THAT'S HOW
WE CAME TO CALIFORNIA IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. AND SO
FROM- MY COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE A
PRAYER EFFORT FOR OUR PEERS IN
LOCKED FACILITIES AND- WE HAVE
HALF A MILLION IN- IN IN- THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM ALREADY
THIS IS A BIG MARKET. FOR
DIAGNOSING WITH MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE- DISORDERS
AND CURRENTLY FEDERALLY THEY ARE
PERMANENT. DISORDERS THE WAS
REMOVED FROM THE FILM WAS
RELEASED A YEAR AGO. AND HAS-
AND I HAVE- WROTE A LETTER. TWO
WEEKS AGO WHEN I WAS HERE ABOUT
THAT SO IT IS ENORMOUS SYSTEM
DYSREGULATION IS EDUCATION HAS
BEEN BLOCKED FROM OUR DOCTORS.
SO NEXT LEGISLATIVE CYCLE I'M
I'M HOPING THAT WE CAN- AND
SUPPORT THESE FOLKS THAT THE
RECEIVE MENTAL HALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DIAGNOSES WITH
TRAUMA- RECOVERY AND
INTEGRATION- SUPPORT AND FOR OUR
DOCTORS ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE
MEDICAL MODEL IS BROKEN THAT OUR
BRAINS ARE NOT BROKEN MY FRIEND
IS NOT BROKEN BUT BUT BUT THE
BUT THE PERVASIVE LANGUAGE OUT
THERE IS THAT. I HAVE A BRAIN
ILLNESS. THIS IS JUST FALSE AND
THIS STARTED WITH PETROLEUM AND
ROCKEFELLER THE WHOLE MEDICAL
MODEL FOUNDATION OF EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED THIRTY SECONDS PLEASE IN
THE LATE EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS. SO
RIGHT NOW IT YOU KNOW WITH WITH
THE IS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS
BEING DECIMATED IN CALIFORNIA
BUT THAT'S BEEN INTENTIONAL BY
NAOMI CALIFORNIA. AND IN THE
PHARMACEUTICAL REPS THAT CONTROL
THE ORGANIZATION NATIONALLY
THEY'VE DECIMATED OUR BEHAVIOR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND THERE
THE- THIS WILL WE NEED FUNDING
FOR THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR SHARING YOUR STORY
APPRECIATED- WE'VE TAKEN OUR
LEAD TESTIMONY NOW WILL GO TO
ARMY TO TESTIMONY IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN THIS ROOM SEEING
NO ONE HERE. MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP. ANY SUPPORT FOR SB
NINE NINE NINE. THE SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. GOOD LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN. WE HAD EIGHTY
SEVEN. I COULD PRETTY MUCH CARE
MEMBERS BREAK DOUGHERTY ON
BEHALF OF SOME OF THE RECOVERY
CENTER IN SARATOGA CALIFORNIA
PRO SPONSORS OF THE BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FINGERLING.
SEVENTY SEVEN. SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WITH A LINE
NINETY FIVE. YES I'M CALLING IN
REGARD TO SB THIRTY ONE THERE
WAS SOMETHING WRONG WITH THE
SYSTEM AND I WAS ASKED TO CALL
BACK IN- CALLING- MY NAME IS
CLARK JAMES THE EXECUTIVE
SECRETARY OF THE ALLIANCE OF
SPECIAL EFFECTS AND PYROTECHNIC
OPERATORS- ON THEIR BEHALF- WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RUNAWAY
PRODUCTION IN THE ECONOMIC COST
TO CALIFORNIA AND OUR JOBS THANK
YOU IN RELATION TO THAT. YEAH
THANK YOU. LINE NINETY FOR YOUR
NEXT. WELL SINCE WITH THE
DEPRESSION AND BIPOLAR SUPPORT
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. HE CURRENTLY NINE
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
GO TO OPPOSITION OF SB NINE NINE
NINE. ANYONE IN THIS ROOM NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM MODERATORS ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO
NINE NINE NINE. IF PRESS ONE
ZERO TO OPPOSE SB NINE NINE NINE
. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION I
SEE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES SO WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE WILL DEAL WITH SB NINE
NINE NINE WITH THE OTHER BILLS
MOVING ON SB TWELVE FORTY FOUR
CORTESE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE PUBLIC RESOURCES
ACCOUNT WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
HEARING WITH FOLKS IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NO RUSH TO THE
MICROPHONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
FOR SUPPORT OF TWELVE FORTY FOUR. PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAINST. ONE ZERO CATHOLIC TO-
SUPPORT. I WILL NOT FORGIVE ME
JUST A MOMENT.
CAPITOLINE. FIFTY EIGHT. YEAH HI
THERE MARK AND WE WOULD
CALIFORNIA WATER FILE- WE ARE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT SHOULD
BE A- TENTH ITEM- THE BILL. FIVE
EIGHT ANY NEW MONEY RATHER THIS
REQUIRES THAT A GREAT ACTIVITIES
THAT ARE LEGALLY EARMARKED FOR
WATER DAHLE PURPOSES ARE
DIRECTED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE. RATHER THAN
OTHER A STATE AGENCY THAT DON'T
HAVE WATER PROPER ROOM THANK YOU
SIR YOU. THANK ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO THE NEXT PERSON. I
EARLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT LET'S GO TO OUR
OPPOSITION AT TWELVE FORTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE IN THIS ROOM APPROACH
KNOW ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO TWELVE FORTY FOUR.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. CURRENTLY NINETY CUTE ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUE WILL CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING ON TWELVE FORTY
FOUR AND WE'LL DEAL WITH IT WHEN
WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL MOVE ON SB
TWELVE NINETY FOUR. BY SENATOR
CORTESE AND WORKFORCE WELLNESS
CENTERS SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING WITH SUPPORT
TESTIMONY THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF TWELVE NINETY FOUR.
PRESS ONE WE'RE SORRY NINE. I'M
SORRY MY MISTAKE WE HAVE A
PRIMARY SUPPORT WITNESS. MISS
KRYSTAL IS BACK PLEASE COME UP.
AGAIN YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES.
THANK YOU SENATOR- SO ARE YOU
I'M FROM- SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND
I AM IN SUPPORT OF. THE OF
WELLNESS CENTER AND COMMUNITY
FOR. OUR SANTA CLARA VALLEY PTA-
WHAT WORD I AND- CONCERNED ABOUT
IS THAT THE WHOLE BEAVER HOUSE
SYSTEM IS BUILT ON A MODEL OF
LEARNED HELPLESSNESS IN ON- IT
IS SO THIS IDEA THAT WE'RE GOING
TO HELP YOU WE'RE GOING TO HELP
THE VTA WORKERS IS IT IT IT IT
IT IT IT PRESUMES THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE STRENGTH TO BRING
TO THE TABLE TO. HELP EACH EACH
OTHER AND THIS. GOES TO THE PEER
SUPPORT- ARMS. MODEL TOO BECAUSE
WE'VE BEEN BASICALLY NEUTERED BY
CAL IMAGES SAY IN THEIR LANGUAGE
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO. LIKE THE
PROVIDERS THAT WE WORK WITH ON
TEAMS. OKAY CAN ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO GAIN INSIGHT FROM US. SO AT-
IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW VTA- YOU
KNOW OF CENTER COURTESIES AS WE
WROTE SOME ABOUT YOUR- YOU KNOW
WE'RE- THIS IS SO VERY PROUD OF
THIS FIRST TIME SPEAKING HERE
AND IN SACRAMENTO- WITH YOU SO-
I DON'T I DON'T KNOW HOW. TO
RECOVER BUT I THINK THE YOU KNOW
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER RE
EDUCATION FOR THE DOCTORS AND
TRAUMA. IS GONNA BE VITAL NEXT
LEGISLATIVE CYCLE AND- BECAUSE-
PHARMACEUTICAL REPS ARE
CONTROLLING THEIR EDUCATION. AT
THE AT THE UNIVERSITY LEVEL BUT
THROUGH THE PA RURAL HEALTH
SYSTEM HOPEFULLY WE CAN- PROVIDE
THEM. WITH- GOOD GOOD EDUCATION
AND- THE NERVOUS SYSTEM OF
CAPACITY FOR RECOVERY. THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR
PRIMARY TESTIMONY IN. A SUPPORT
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
SUPPORT OF TWELVE NINETY FOUR.
PRESS ONE DIRECTORS FIND SUPPORT. CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF TWELVE
NINETY FOUR THERE'S NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM COMING UP TO THE
MICROPHONE MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
TWELVE NINETY FOUR. YOU CAN PUT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME TO A- THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
AND WE SEE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES FROM WE HAVE A CLOSE
THE PUBLIC HEARING ON TWELVE
NINETY FOUR WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM WILL DEAL WITH THAT BILL
MOVE ON SB TWELVE NINETY SEVEN
CORTESE LOW EMBODIED CARBON
BUILDING MATERIALS CARBON
SEQUESTRATION IT'S A SUSPENSE
KENNEDY'S WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PIKE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT HERE IN
TWELVE TWENTY TWO HUNDRED NO
ONE'S HERE MODERATOR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN. IF YOU
PLEASE SUPPORT FOR SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE. WE CAN GO TO
LINE. SIXTY SIX. MEMBERS
DOCUMENT ON HERE ON THE U. S.
GREEN BUILDING COUNCIL AND LAW
CENTER LEADS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ITS B. CORP NINETY SEVEN
THANK YOU. AND AGAIN IT'S ONE
ZERO WE HAVE TWENTY Q. GIVE ME
JUST A MOMENT. AND LINE NINETY
SIXTY NINE IS OPEN. I WISH I
RELAX THEM. ONE ZERO. SUPPORT
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN NOW IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY. AND NOBODY HERE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY HERE WE GO I
WILL OPEN UP THE LINE NINETY SIX
. HELLO I'M CALLING FOR SUPPORT.
FOR WESTERN CARBON. OF THREE.
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO US YOU
. CARBON GOING THE- THANK YOU.
IN CURRENTLY NO FURTHER IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION
TO TWELVE NINETY SEVEN IS THERE
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED NO
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN. I COMPOSED PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES SO I WILL
CLOSE THE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
TWELVE NINETY SEVEN WILL DEAL
WITH THAT WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM
SB THIRTEEN FIFTEEN CORTESE
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE CONSUMPTION
AREA PERMITS IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING IN TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SEAT NO RUSSIAN THE
MICROPHONE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF SB. THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN. PRESS ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN FIFTEENTH.
THANK YOU CURRENTLY ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
RUSHING TO THE MICROPHONE
OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN FIFTEEN
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSE THE THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN. IF PRESS ONE ZERO.
EARLY NINETY TWO ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION AND
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND WE'LL DEAL WITH THAT
BILL AND WE HAVE A PARMESAN SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE ALSO BY
SENATOR CORTESE ON ELECTRICITY
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING LOCAL SOLAR
PROGRAM WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY AT THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE. PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
RUSSIAN IN THE MICROPHONE
OPPOSED TO EIGHT THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE MODERATOR LET'S OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINE FOR OPPOSITION TO SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE. THE FIRST
ONE HERE AT THIS TIME. EARLY
NINETIES YOU ALL RIGHT WE TAKE
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WE
HAVE NO QUESTIONS SO I'LL CLOSE
THE PUBLIC HEARING ON THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE AND WILL BE WITH
THAT BUILDING WE HAVE A FORM.
WILL MOVE ON TO S. B. EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT BY DR PAN ON HEALTH
CARE PRESCRIPTION DRUGS IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE DOCTOR'S
WAY PRESENTATION TO OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WITH NO ONE
AT THE MICROPHONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE. FOR TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT THREE EIGHT
. PRESS. ONE ZERO. I WANT TO
GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT AGAIN IT'S.
ONE ZERO.
MEDICARE. WE CAN OPEN LINE
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU. OKAY
CURRENTLY NINETY FIFTH THE FIND
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION
TO THE SP EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED EIGHT THREE EIGHT
BY DR PAN RUN SP EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT. DR PAN. PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. HE CURRENTLY NINETY
Q. ALL RIGHT WILL WILL- GOES TO
OUR COLLEAGUES NO ONE IS RAISING
THEIR HAND WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OFF CLOSE THE PUBLIC
HEARING AND SB EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT. AND WE WILL DEAL WITH
THAT WHEN WE COME BACK WITH A
QUORUM WILL GO RIGHT TO SB NINE
OH SEVEN BY DR PAN ON ELECTRONIC
BENEFITS TRANSFER SYSTEM FARMERS
MARKETS. ANYONE IN SUPPORT WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING FOR
YOU NOW THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
OH SEVEN. YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THREE NINETY
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK TO
THE ROOM FOR OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE OH SEVEN. THERE'S NO ONE
HERE MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB NINE OH
SEVEN BY DR PAM. YES PLEASE
PRESS ONE DIRECTORS TIME. EARLY
NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS NO FILE NO QUESTIONS
AND NO QUORUM. THAT'S A TRIFOLD
NINE NO ALL RIGHT WE'LL DEAL
WITH THAT WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM
WILL COME AND WE'LL CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING WILL GO RIGHT TO
SB TEN EIGHTEEN ON DOCTOR PAN ON
PLATFORM ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. WE WILL OPEN THE
PUBLIC HEARING IN TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NO ONE HERE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT
OF SB TEN EIGHTEEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THIRTY AS FAR AS WE CAN
EIGHTEEN AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO.
CURRENTLY NINE Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION TO TEN EIGHTEEN
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB TEN
EIGHTEEN. THESE PRESS ONE ZERO.
CURRENTLY NINE Q. RIGHT WITH
TECH IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WE WILL CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING AND WE'LL DEAL
WITH THAT WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM.
WILL MOVE ON TO SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
DR PAN MEDI CAL TIME AND
DISTANCE STANDARDS FOR MANAGED
CARE SERVICES WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
RIGHT HERE IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF ELEVEN
EIGHTY. PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
ORDER SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL COME BACK TO THIS ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN EIGHTY
THERE'S NOBODY IN THE ROOM
MODERATORS ANYONE OPPOSED TO S.
B. ELEVEN EIGHTY. AND IT'S ONE
ZERO WHAT WAS. CURRENTLY NINETY
Q. RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF ELEVEN EIGHTY WILL
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING THERE'S
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WE WILL DEAL WITH SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY ONE WE HAVE A CORE MOVING
ON SB EIGHT FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR OCADO ON COVERT NINETEEN
RELIEF TENNESSEE GRANT PROGRAMS
TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
SENATORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY. IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHT FORTY SEVEN IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE OF
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
FOUR SEVEN. PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME TO SUPPORT. HE
CURRENTLY NINETY YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK TO OPPOSITION TO
THE SP EIGHT FORTY SEVEN THERE'S
NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB EIGHT
FORTY SEVEN. AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO
TWO OPPOSE AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION SO WE'LL
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING I SEE
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WHO WILL DEAL WITH EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN WE HAVE A QUORUM. SB TEN
EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR HER TADO
ON PROPERTY OWNERSHIP FARM
OWNERSHIP AND FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IF SUPPORTERS OF SB
TEN EIGHTY FOUR. I GUESS ONE
DIRECTION SUPPORT. CURRENTLY
NINETY Q. WILL COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED OPPOSED TO TEN EIGHTY
FOUR MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB TEN EIGHTY
FOUR. YEAH THAT'S ONE ZERO TWO
OPPOSE AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY
MANY Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
TO WALK CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WILL DEAL WITH SB TEN
EIGHTY FOUR WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM. WE'RE MOVING ON SB TEN
NINETY TWO BY SENATOR HER TADO
AND DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES IT IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION AND WILL OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC HEARING IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY PRESENT TO SPEAK ON IT
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE. TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY SUPPORT
TESTIMONY FOR TEN NINETY TWO. I
CAN EXPECT TO SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF TEN NINETY TWO
THERE'S NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TEN NINETY
TWO.
BOTTERILL AT I'M SORRY IT'S ONE
DIRECTORS TIME. THANK CURRENTLY
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF TEN NINETY TWO I
WILL CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING
AND NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES SO WE WILL DEAL WITH
SB TEN NINETY TWO WHEN WE COME
BACK WITH A QUORUM SB EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR WIENER ON
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS
DISCIPLINE CIVIL PENALTIES. IT'S
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC HEARING IN SUPPORT IN
ROOM TWO. TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
THERE'S NO ONE HERE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT
. PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK TO THIS ROOM FOR OPPOSITION
OF SB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT IS THERE
ANYONE OPPOSED EIGHT FIFTY
EIGHTEEN NO ONE AT THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINE FOR OPPOSITION
SB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY NINETY YOU WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT SO I WILL CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT WE WILL DEAL WITH THIS
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL MOVE
ON SB EIGHT EIGHT SIX BY SENATOR
WIENER ON SEA QUEST. AND PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES WITH HOUSING WE
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT RIGHT HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
HUSTLED TO THE SPEAKER THE TO
THIS MICROPHONE MIKE MULLIGAN
AND WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WE ARE CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL. ROGER SUPPORT. ALEX
ON THESE ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT
SEE NO ONE ELSE AT THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD QUEUE OF ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHT EIGHT SIX.
PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO FOUR.
GIVE ME A MOMENT HERE. AND WE
CAN OPEN LINE EIGHTY NINE. SHARE
IS BOB NAIL REPRESENTING FUEL
SEVEN THAT POWER- INS YOU NEARLY
AN ORANGE COUNTY- PLAN SERVICE
IS STRONG STILL. AND CURRENTLY
KNOWN FOR THEIR ISSUE ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK TO THIS ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION OF EIGHT EIGHT SIX
THERE'S NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
MODERATORS FOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED EIGHT EIGHT
SIX. THE POST PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIRECTED CRIME. CURRENTLY NINETY
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT EIGHT SIX
WE HAVE NO MISTER MAYOR HAS A
COMMENT OR QUESTION NO I HAVE A
COMMENT BECAUSE I CHAIR THE
EDUCATION BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE.
IN THE GOVERNOR. AND THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR DID TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION HOUSING OVER THREE
YEARS. IT WAS OVER SUBSCRIBED TO
BY OVER A BILLION DOLLARS. THE
GOVERNOR DIDN'T REALLY PUT MUCH
ADDITIONAL IN THIS YEAR BUT THE
LEGISLATURE SATURDAY BILLION AND
A HALF DOLLARS AND- OR THE
SENATE HAS AND ITS PLAN ANDI
REALLY HOPE WE CAN KEEP IT IN
BECAUSE TO ME. THE ISSUE IS NOT
THE PROCESS THE ISSUE IS MAKING
SURE WE HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
BUILD AS MUCH HOUSING AS WE CAN
AND THAT'S WHAT WE ARE WORKING
TO DO. I JUST WANTED TO NOTE
THAT AND THAT'LL BE AT ISSUE IN
THE IN THE BUDGET COMING UP
THANK YOU SIR FOR THAT COMMENT.
WE HAVE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION AND WE WILL DEAL WITH
THIS FROM WE HAVE A QUORUM. SO
WE'LL MOVE ON SB NINE TWENTY
THREE BY SENATOR WIENER ON
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE. WILL OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT. THERE'S NOBODY HERE AT
THE MICROPHONE MODERATORS OR
ANYONE AT THE PHONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT YOUR OPPOSITION
. YES WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
SUPPORT FIRST. ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE
LINE NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LINES OPEN. THOSE ALSO
WRITTEN QUESTIONS BIPOLAR
SUPPORT ALLIANCE WE ARE IN
SUPPORT WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
VERIFICATION OF THE- BUT WAY.
APPROACH BEFORE GOING THROUGH
THE WE DO SUPPORT. EARLY NINE
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN THE SUPPORT BEFORE WE GOT
OPPOSITION A MISTER CONSULTANT
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM SO IF YOU
COULD CALL THE ROLL SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A- MORE. WITH SENATOR
PORTANTINO I'M HERE PORTANTINO
HERE SENATOR BATES. CENTER
BRADFORD. SENATOR JONES. SENATOR
KAMLAGER. YEAH YEAH CENTER
KAMLAGER HERE CENTER LAYER HERE
EARLIER HERE CENTER LIKE ASKING
WHY CASKEY SAY HERE WE- SAY HERE
HERE WHY CASKEY MONTHS HERE WHY
CASKEY HERE TO FOUR MEMBERS
PRESENT WE HAVE FOUR MEMBERS
PRESENT WE STRUGGLE TO GET. WE
STRUGGLE TO GET WE STRUGGLE TO
GET A QUORUM SO WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND SO- THIS MEETING IS
OFFICIALLY IN ORDER AND WE WILL
GO TO- ARE OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
OF S. B. NINE TWENTY THREE. MISS
KRYSTAL IS HERE AGAIN YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES. THANK YOU
SENATORS. EARNED FOR. SO THE
REASON THAT I'M LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS IS THAT THERE
IS- THERE'S- THERE'S A BROADER
AGENDA GOING ON IN AMERICA-
WAITED GENDER CHRISTIAN AGENDA.
AND- THAT'S FOMENTING A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS IN AMERICA AND
AROUND THE WORLD. AND THE
MEDICAID EXPANSION IS
SPECIFICALLY TARGETING PEOPLE OF
COLOR CHILDREN TRANSGENDER- TWO
WERE TO GROW. THAT SYSTEM AND-
TO LABEL OUR FOLKS WITH AN IRON
I'VE BEEN SAYING YOU KNOW A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND FOR A WHILE
YOU KNOW THAT WE NEED TEMPORARY
LABELS THAT PSYCHIATRY IS AN ART
IT'S NOT A SCIENCE. AND- IT'S-
HE YOU KNOW AS A AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER IT'S NOT AN ILLNESS WERE
. CLIFFORD BEERS IN NINETEEN OH
WAIT HE WROTE THE BOOK A MIND
THAT FOUND ITSELF. SO WE HAVE
DECADES. OF A RECOVERY MOVEMENT
. BUT WE DIDN'T WE HAD A PRESS
CONFERENCE TWO WEEKS AGO. DID
DID THE LOCAL TELEVISION STATION
KHON NO. ASSEMBLY GET TELEVISION
TIME THE SHOW FOR BIG PHARMA YES
. SO BY YOUR THIS CALL ASPECTS
OF THE BILL THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL OAY THANK YOU SENATOR.
SOME OF MY CONCERNS ABOUT THIS-
AROUND PRIVACY. SO NOW WITH OKAY
OKAY- IN IN MY COUNTY SECRETARY
WHENEVER I GO FOR SERVICES. I TO
AN EVENT I AM PROFILED. SO ARE
AT IT AND THEY'RE PUSHING THIS
THERE ARE PROFILING US IN- IT IT
IT IN AND THEY'RE USING OUR TAX
DOLLARS. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
TAKEN OUR PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR OPPOSITION OF NINE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION. AND AGAIN IT'S ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. INCRIMINATING
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION TO SEE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES SO
I'M GOING TO READ A LIST OF
BILLS AND- IF WITHOUT OBJECTION
ALL OF THESE BILLS WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE OF MY COLLEAGUES DON'T
HAVE ANY OBJECTIONS. I'M GONNA
DO READ THE LIST AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION THEY WILL ALL BE SENT
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE SB EIGHT
TWENTY NINE. SB NINE THIRTY TWO
SB TEN SIXTY SEVEN SB ELEVEN
THIRTY SIX SB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
SB EIGHT THIRTY ONE SB NINE NINE
NINE SB TWELVE FOUR FOUR SB
TWELVE NINETY FOUR SB TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN. SB THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE.
SB EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT SB NINE OH
SEVEN SB TEN EIGHTEEN SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SB EIGHT FORTY SEVEN SB
TEN EIGHTY FOUR SB TEN NINETY
TWO SB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT. SB
EIGHT EIGHT SIX SB NINE TWENTY
THREE AND OUR SPECIAL ORDER
BUSINESS SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT
ENTIRE LIST OF BILLS WILL GO TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE SEEING NO
OBJECTION SO ORDERED. WILL MOVE
ON TO SB THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX BY
SENATOR WIENER AND INCOME TAXES
CREDIT CANNABIS BUSINESS
QUALIFIED EXPENSES. IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. PERCENT MY
MICROPHONE WAS OFF SO I NEED TO
READ THAT ALL OVER AGAIN.
MICROPHONE WE HEAR YOU HEAR. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA DO THAT ONE
MORE TIME. WE HAVE A QUORUM THE
FOLLOWING BILLS WITH AS LONG AS
THERE'S NO OBJECTION THE
FOLLOWING LIST OF BILLS WILL GO
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. I WILL
READ THE LIST AND THEN MAKE AN
ORDER SUBJECT TO WHETHER THERE'S
OBJECTION OR NOT. THE LIST THE
BILLS ARE SB EIGHT TWENTY NINE
SB NINE THIRTY TWO SB TEN SIXTY
SEVEN SB ELEVEN THIRTY SIX SB
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE SB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE SB NINE NINE NINE SB
TWELVE FORTY FOUR SB TWELVE
NINETY FOUR SB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN. SB THIRTEEN FIFTEEN SB IN
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE SB EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT SB NINE OH SEVEN SB
TEN EIGHTEEN SB ELEVEN EIGHTY S.
B. EIGHT FORTY SEVEN SB TEN
EIGHTY FOUR SB TEN NINETY TWO SB
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT SB EIGHT EIGHT
SIX SB NINE TWENTY THREE. SHOW
ALL N. ARE SPECIAL ORDER
BUSINESS WHICH IS S. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY THREE THANKS TO ME AT
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT THAT'S IT
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT ARE
SPECIAL ORDER BUSINESS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. ALL OF THOSE BILLS
WILL BE SENT TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE SINGLE OBJECTION SO
ORDERED. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX BY
SENATOR WIENER ON INCOME TAX
CREDITS CANNABIS. IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE
IN ROOM THIRTY IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. ARE YOU IN SUPPORT
YES I'VE ALL RIGHT TELL US YOUR
NAME HELLO FERGUSON ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
BLACK CAUCUS LET'S COMMITTEE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
SIR ANYONE ELSE SEEING NO ONE
ELSE MODERATOR PLEASE GO TO THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ORDER RICK. YES ONE
ZERO GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT. ONE
OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOW
TO LOG ON BEHALF OF THE FTW
FUNCTORS OF THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THE CORNER.
FOR MANY OTHERS. I CURRENTLY
NONE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT WILL COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN
THIRTY SIX. ONE ZERO TWO NINE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB EIGHT
SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR UMBERG ARE
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTIONS IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATIONAL OPEN UP
PUBLIC TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE SO
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT-SIXTY TWO. IF PRESS ONE ZERO SL. EARLY NINETEEN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION
OF SB EIGHT SIXTY TWO THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB EIGHT SIXTY TWO. YES
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY
NINE RETAKE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION A SPEECH SIXTY TWO
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE SB TEN SIXTY
NINE ALSO BY SENATOR UMBERG
STATE GRANT PROGRAMS IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATOR
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR
SUPPORT OF TEN SIXTY NINE. EACH
PRESS ONE YOUR SUPPORT. YES ONE
ZERO TO SUPPORT SB CAN FIFTY
NINE. ME A MOMENT HERE.
RIGHT WILL OPEN LINE. ONE
ELEVEN. AND IT LOOKS LIKE IT TO
COME SOUTH PARK YOU AGAIN PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU NEED TO COME
BACK IN. IT'S ONE ZERO. THANK
YOU CURRENTLY ALL RIGHT WE'LL
COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION OF TEN
SIXTY NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TEN SIXTY
NINE. THAT'S ONE ZERO INFO. HE
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND THERE'S
NO QUESTION SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB TEN SIXTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB EIGHT SIXTY
THREE BY SENATOR MAN ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATORS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. EIGHT SIXTY THREE. HERE AGAIN
ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
. HE CURRENTLY NINETY Q. WILL
COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION AND
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSE STATE SIXTY
THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIRECTORS TRYING. HE CURRENTLY
NINE Q. WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB EIGHT SIXTY THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO SB EIGHT H.
ONE WILL OPEN UP THE IT IS OUR
DOCTOR SENATOR MEN ON LOAD
SERVING ENTITIES IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
FROM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. MODERATOR'S ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE SUPPORT OF
EIGHT EIGHT ONE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THERE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK
FOR OPPOSITION OF EIGHT EIGHT
ONE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED MODERATE OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB EIGHT
EIGHT ONE. ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT EIGHT
ONE OF WE'VE BEEN JOINED BY THE
AYE MAN. AND SO. WITHOUT ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT EIGHT
ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING
ON S. B. NINE SEVEN FIVE ON DECK
CORE'S COURSE DEBTIT IS ALSO BY
SENATOR MINIS WAY PRESENTATION
AND IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVENTY FIVE. THERE'S NOBODY AT
THE MICROPHONE WILL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE PHONE LINE
MODERATORS ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF
NINE SEVENTY FIVE. EACH PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY
NINE FURTHER NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB NINE SEVEN FIVE
. EIGHT THREE PRESS ONE THERE AT
THIS TIME. ONE ZERO GIVE ME JUST
A MOMENT HERE.
AND WE'VE GOT ONE HERE WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE THIRTEENTH. AND WHAT
IS YOUR MEMBERS MELANIE CUEVAS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE SEVENTY
FIVE WITHOUT OBJECTION NINE
SEVENTY FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
. WILL MOVE ON T SB NINE OH
FOUR BY SENATOR BATES ON
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE TREATMENT
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAVE. PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT RIGHT HERE
IS NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE- IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE OH
FOUR. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ITSELF. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO OPPOSITION
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATORS FOR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO NINE OH
FOUR. EACH PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. HE CURRENTLY NOT IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE OH FOUR
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES- WE WILL WITHOUT
OBJECTION SENT SB NINE OH FOUR
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE MOVING ON
SB ELEVEN NINETY ONE ALSO BY
SENATOR BATES A MEDIC CAL.
FORMER PHARMA COME. FROM NOT CAN
EVEN TRY TO SAY THAT WORD
TESTING. IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. WE WILL OPEN UP THE
PART AND SHE'S WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM. MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF ELEVEN NINETY ONE.
THE FARMER IN THEM PHARMA
CONSCIONABLE MAKE. HELLO CODE
GENOMICS. ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT AND- ONE WOMAN
HERE WITH YOUR HAVE A COUPLE
YEARS AGO FOR A LINE. NINETY
FOUR. BUT PAUL SIMONS WITH THE
MACHINE BIPOLAR SUPPORT
ALLIANCE. STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
FIFTEEN LETTER WORD. YES ALL
RIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN NINETY ONE I. IF THERE IS
YOU ME JUST A MOMENT. LINE FIFTY
ONE YOU'RE OPEN. HI I'M MEGHAN
VOID ON BEHALF OF THE TAKE
CORPORATION AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN NINETY ONE
THANK YOU. I AM CURRENTLY NINE
FURTHER ACCUSED I WILL COME BACK
FOR OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN
NINETY ONE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO ELEVEN NINETY
ONE. THE POST PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. HE CURRENTLY
NINE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE TAKE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION THAT
WE'VE LEARNED HOW TO SAY THE
WORDS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB THIRTEEN
FORTY TWO BY SENATOR BATES VICE
CHAIR BATES ON AGING MULTI
DISCIPLINARY PERSONNEL TEAMS. IT
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN FORTY TWO. ACTUALLY
COMMITTEE FOR ONE ZERO. THANK
YOU FOR TO THANK YOU AND AGAIN
IT'S ONE ZERO TWO SUPPORT SB
THIRTEEN FORTY TWO. CURRENTLY
NINE Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK FOR OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY TWO THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO THIRTEEN FORTY TWO. A POST
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK YOU
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN FORTY TWO
WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB THIRTEEN FORTY TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO SENATOR
RUBIO SB NINE FOURTEEN HELP
ACTED AS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. AND THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATOR WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINE. ON SUPPORT FOR
SB. NINE FOURTEEN. ANDERSON PART
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO S. B. NINE FOURTEEN. A THE
POLICE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
THANK YOU WE TAKE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO QUESTIONS
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE
FOURTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON SB TWELVE SIXTY FIVE BY
SEVEN TO RUBIO AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE CHILDREN VISITATION IS
THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION. WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC HEARING IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATORS
FOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF TWELVE SIXTY FIVE.
HERE AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO.
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION
OF TWELVE SIXTY FIVE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM- MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE ARE
YOU WANTING TO OPPOSE TWELVE
SIXTY FIVE NO OKAY SURE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB.
TWELVE SIXTY FIVE. THIS PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
AND SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWELVE SIXTY FIVE WILL MOVE TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE WILL BE ON SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
RUBIO ON COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING. IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION SO WE WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING. IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATOR'S
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
. SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. IT CURRENTLY NINE. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK TO
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM THIS IS OPPOSITION TIME FOR
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN MODERATOR
ANYONE OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. IF PRESS ONE ZERO
TO OPPOSE. CURRENTLY MANY Q. ALL
RIGHT W'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION FOURTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB NINE
TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR ARCH
ALETTA ON LIFE INSURANCE IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE SENATORS
WAY PRESENTATION. WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE
IN THIS WONDERFUL ROOM SEEING
NOBODY RUSHED TO THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE I'M SUPPORT FOR SB NINE
TWENTY SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO SUPPORT SB NINE TWENTY
SEVEN. CURRENTLY NINE Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE TWENTY
SEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
SB. NINE TWENTY SEVEN. THESE
PRESS ONE ZERO TO OPPOSE.
ENDEMIC YOU CURRENTLY ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
AND THERE'S NO QUESTION SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB NINE TWENTY
SEVEN GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
SB TEN SEVENTY SIX BY ENTER
ARCHULETA ON LEAD BASED PAINT
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAVE PRESENTATION LOOKS
LIKE WE HAVE SOMEBODY COMING TO
THE MICROPHONE TO SUPPORT SB TEN
SEVENTY SIX. GOOD MORNING TACK
ALLEN ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE FOR THE
CITY PEOPLE C. P. BLACK CAUCUS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NO ONE ELSE IS HERE
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF SB TEN
SEVENTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I GUESS ONE
ZERO GO TO LINE WELL. LAURA
ROSENBERGER HIGHER I SUPPORT AND
THE SB. TEN FIFTY SIX FRESNO
THANK YOU. AND CURRENTLY NONE
FURTHER IN Q. WILL COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TEN SEVENTY
SIX THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB TEN SEVEN SIX.
IT'S PAST ONE ZERO TWO OPPOSE AT
THIS TIME. CURRENTLY NINETY Q.
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TEN SEVENTY
SIX I HAVE NO QUESTIONS SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN SEVENTY
SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON TO SB NINE SEVENTY BY SENATOR
EGGMAN ON MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
SENATORS WAY PRESENTATION. SO
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVEN
ZERO. THE FIRST ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'VE OPENED UP FOR SUPPORT
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB NINE
SEVENTY. PRESS ONE DIRECTORS
TRYING TO OPPOSE. YOU HAVE ONE
WILL GO TO LINE NINETY FOUR.
THIS IS PAUL SIMONS WITH THE
RUSSIAN BIPOLAR SUPPORT ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSING
THIS BILL. AND CURRENTLY KNOWN
FOR THEIR ISSUE ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION I'VE NO
QUESTION SO THAT OBJECTION SB
NINE SEVENTY WILL GO TO SUSPEND
TO SPEAK TEN SIXTY FIVE BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. AND CALIFORNIA
BANDON AND DERELICT COMMERCIAL
VESSELS PROGRAM IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF TEN SIXTY
FIVE. PRESS ONE DIRECTION
SUPPORT. CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE SUPPORT
THAT'S GOOD OPPOSITION OF TEN
SIXTY FIVE IS THERE ANYONE HERE
KNOW MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED. TO TEN SIXTY
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE DIRECTORS
TIME. IT CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO QUESTION
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN
SIXTY FIVE ABOUT A SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON SB TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR EGGMAN A BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SERVICES IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION SO WE WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATORS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE- THAT IS IN
SUPPORT OF. TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO SO.
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION FOR S. B.
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO SO. AND CURRENTLY
NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT WE TAKE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WE HAVE
NO QUESTIONS SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. L. TWELVE THIRTY
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPEND MOVING
ON SB THIRTEEN ELEVEN BY SENATOR
EGGMAN ON VETERANS PROTECTIONS
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHOR HAS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR
ANYONE IS ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN ELEVEN. HE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME. AND CURRENTLY MANY
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION FOR SB THIRTEEN
ELEVEN THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED THE THIRTEEN
LEFT. PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND CURRENTLY NINETY Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THIRTEEN ELEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB TEN
FIFTEEN BY SENATOR HUESO ON
STATE ENERGY RESOURCE
CONSERVATION AND DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION THE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION SO WITHOUT FURTHER
ADO WE WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FIFTEEN THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TEN FIFTEEN. PRESS ONE HERE AT
THIS TIME. HE CURRENTLY NINETY
Q. AND LESSEN THEIR LAST TAX WAS
A MISTAKE RIGHT I'M GOING TO GO
OVER NOW BE RIGHT BACK OKAY I'M
SORRY WHERE WERE WE- SIMPLE ANY
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME FOR OPPOSITION AT TEN
FIFTEEN- THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TEN
FIFTEEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE TO A
COUPLE'S. CURRENTLY NINETY Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TEN FIFTEEN WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON SB TWELVE OH EIGHT BY
SENATOR HUESO AND YET LOW INCOME
UTILITY CUSTOMER ASSISTANCE. IT
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT AND ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE
AWAIT. IT'S PAST ONE ZERO TO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION
OF SB TWELVE AWAIT BY SENATOR
HUESO THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TWELVE
AWAIT. IF PRESS ONE THIRTY
OPPOSE SB TWELVE AWAIT. THANK
YOU CURRENTLY ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB
TWELVE AWAY AND WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN BY SENATOR HUESO IN
CALIFORNIA GLOBAL WARMING
SOLUTIONS ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SIX. IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WE
WILL OPEN UP FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT RIGHT HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WITH
NOBODY HERE. MOVE ON TO THE
PHONE LINE FOR SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN. TO SUPPORT
SB THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT
WILL COME TO OPPOSITION OF
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN THERE'S
NOBODY HERE OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN MODERATORS ANYONE
OPPOSED ON THE PHONE LINE
THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN. AND TO
OPPOSE SB THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. HE CURRENTLY MANY Q. WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORTOPPOSITION THERE'S
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
SO THAT OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON SB THIRTEEN FIFTY NINE
BY SENATOR WE SWAY SO ON VEHICLE
REGISTRATION IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. CENTERS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN
FIFTY NINE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE FOR SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN
FIFTY NINE. HERE AGAIN IS THREE
ONE ZERO THE POOREST. AND
CURRENTLY NINETY QUEUE ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION
OF THIRTEEN FIFTY NINE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN FIFTY NINE.
PRESS ONE DIRECTORS TIME TO
OPPOSE. AND CURRENTLY NINETY Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AT THIRTEEN FIFTY
NINE SO WITH OUT OBJECTION AND
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THIRTEEN FIFTY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB TEN TWENTY
SIX BY SENATOR WHITE COW SKI ON
RESIDENTIAL ENERGY EFFICIENCY-
IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION WILL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN TWENTY SIX. IT
ONE DIRECTORS. TO I WILL BE HERE
THIS TIME BUT WE DO HAVE ONE IN
THE CHEST A MOMENT. WELL
ALLIANCE. SIXTY SIX. I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE YEAR GREEN
BUILDING COUNCIL ANTILLES IN
SUPPORT OF- CANADA WHY BECAUSE
GETS BUILT THANK YOU. AND
CURRENTLY NONE FOR THEIR QUEUE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION
OF SB TEN TWENTY SIX. AND
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATOR- IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TEN
TWENTY SIX. IF YOU AGAIN IF I
ONE ZERO. ONE MOMENT HERE. BACK
IN WE CAN APPLYING. TWENTY
SEVEN. YES GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SCREEN THREE C.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
OPPOSITION WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON SB TEN
TWENTY SIX RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTED NO GO TO THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU. AND
CURRENTLY NONE FURTHER IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. OF SB TEN TWENTY SIX
WITHOUT OBJECTION NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWENTY TEN
TWENTY SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVIE ON SB TEN NINETY NINE ALSO
BY SENATOR WHITE CAL SKI ON
BANKRUPTCY. IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT. OF SB
TEN NINETY NINE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE- IN
SUPPORT OF TEN NINETY NINE.
AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. ONE ZERO.
ANCHORMAN ANNIE Q. ALL RIGHT
WILL COME NOT POSITION SO COME
ON UP MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
SENATORS ALEX ELENI'S ON BEHALF
OF THE TRUSTEES FOR- VISIBLE
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTIONS AND THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGMENT PRESERVATION
ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION TO SB TEN
NINETY NINE- WE BELIEVE IT'LL-
CREATE- SIGNIFICANT COST
PRESSURES TO THE GENERAL FUND-
THE HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION PART OF
IT IT REPLIES TO APPRECIATION
AND A HOME AFTER BANKRUPTCY HAS
BEEN FILED. YOU ONE THOUGH-
THOSE RATES WERE INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN A YEAR
AND A HALF AGO- ANYWHERE BETWEEN
THREE HUNDRED AND 50% TO A
HUNDRED PERCENT- THIS THEN
INCREASES IT BY ADDING THE
APPRECIATION IN THE HOME- THAT'S
GONNA BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
DETERMINE FROM THE TIME AND IT
WAS FILED BANKRUPTCY TO WHEN
THEY'RE TRYING TO GO AHEAD AND-
DISPERSALS FUNDS WHICH WILL
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL LITIGATION
IN THAT AREA WHICH WILL THEN
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL COURT COSTS
WILL COME BACK TO THE GENERAL
FUND. ALSO IN ANALYSIS WITH IT
WAS- WELL PUT THE REDUCTION FROM
18% TO TEN PERCENT- ON THE
INTERESTS OF THAT THE LOCALS
WILL ACTUALLY BE COLLECTING-
WILL RESULT IN A REDUCTION IN
THEIR REVENUE WHICH THAT MAY
RESULT IN A- A MANDATE TO THE
STATE WHICH WOULD THEN HAVE TO
COME OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND SO
WITH THAT- WE WOULD ASK THE BILL
BE. SENT TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
THANK YOU. SING NO ONE ELSE COME
TO THEM. OF TEN NINE NINE MY- OR
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION ON TEN
NINETY NINE. PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE WILL LINE ONE
THIRTY. GOOD MORNING CALIFORNIA
BANKERS AND CONFUSION ALSO IN
OUR PRODUCTION. YOU MOMENT GOT A
COUPLE MORE HERE.
IN LINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE MORNING QUESTION
LICHTENBERGER WOULD JUSTICE
MATTERS- WE VERY STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB TEN NINETY NINE AND
ONE HALF THAT IT GETS PUT INTO
SUSPEND THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE
NINETY EIGHT. HELLO ANTHONY
O'NEILL WITH WALGREEN DENTURES
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
WELL. FURTHER I CAN'T ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN NINETY NINE
AND SEEING NO OBJECTIONS IN THE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TEN NINETY NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON SB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI ON CARBON CAPTURE
TECHNOLOGY IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. SURE
MEMBERS MIKE MONEY CAN BE HALF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES WE WERE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED. SENATOR
Y. CASI GRACIOUSLY ACCEPTED OUR
AMENDMENTS WERE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION AND WILL BE IN
SUPPORT. SHORTLY THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE MODERATOR IN SUPPORT
OF THIRTEEN NINETY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THE PHONE. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK
FOR OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM MODERATORS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO
THIRTEEN NINETY NINE. A POST
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN NINETY
NINE WILL MOVE TO SUSPEND TO
SPEAK TEN THIRTY TWO BY SENATOR
PACKER. I'M PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WHERE IT ALL
HAPPENS. THERE'S NO ONE HERE TO
SEE IT HAPPEN. AND SO WE'LL GO
TO THE PHONE LINE. FOR SUPPORT
OF SB TEN THIRTY TWO. IF THE
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION
AND THERE'S NO OPPOSITION ON TEN
THIRTY TWO MODERATE OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TEN
THIRTY TWO. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND CURRENTLY
MANAGES ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF TEN THIRTY
TWO. NO QUESTIONS SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TEN THIRTY TWO WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB TEN
FIFTY NINE BY SENATOR BECKER. ON
PRIVACY DATA BROKERS IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION SO WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF SB TEN FIFTY NINE. FOR ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM KNOW MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
. TWO TEN SHE MAKES THE PORT OF
TEN FIFTY NINE. IF PRESS WONDER
TO SUPPORT SB. TEN FIFTY NINE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK FROM POSITION AT TEN FIFTY
NINE IS NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO TEN FIFTY
NINE. EACH PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND CURRENTLY NINETY
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO QUESTION
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN
FIFTY NINE WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
MOVIE AND S. B. TEN NINETY FOUR
BY SENATOR PACKER ON LOCAL
PLANNING THE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION.
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE AND TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF TEN NINETY
FOUR. PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IF YOU CURRENTLY. ALL
RIGHT WHAT OPPOSITION OF TEN
NINETY FOUR THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM MODERATES OR ANYONE
OPPOSING TEN NINETY FOUR. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TWO OPPOSED.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT- QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WILL CLOSE
THE PUBLIC COMMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AS WE TEN NINETY FOUR
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
PACKER ON RETAIL ELECTRICITY
SUPPLIES TO SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION ME WE'RE GONNA
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT FOR
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
. NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT. REPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK TO THIS
ROOM FOR OPPOSITION OF SB ELEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT IS THERE ANYONE
OPPOSED SB ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT.
NOBODY'S HERE MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT. PRESS ONE
ZERO SUPPOSED. CURRENTLY MANY Q.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ELEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB ELEVEN FIFTY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WILL BE ON SB THIRTEEN
OH ONE BY SENATOR BACKGROUND
CORPORATION TAX LAW PERSONAL
INCOME TAX LAW CREDITS GREEN
ENERGY MATH MANUFACTURING IT IS
A TAX LEVY AND IT IS OPEN NOW
FOR PUBLIC TESTIMONY AND SUPPORT
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
THERE'S NOBODY AT THE MICROPHONE
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTEEN OH ONE. PRESS ONE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK TO OPPOSITION OF
THIRTEEN OH ONE IS OR ANYONE
OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN OH ONE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO THIRTEEN OH ONE. IF
PRESS WONDER TO OPPOSE IT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND THERE'S
NO QUESTION SO THAT OBJECTION S.
B. THIRTEEN NO ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SB TEN FORTY ONE BY PRO
TEM ATKINS ON THE SALES AND USE
TAXES GENERAL EXEMPTIONS ALSO
TAX LEVY IT IS. SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE PRO TEMAS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY SUPPORTED ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TEN FORTY ONE. PORT OF TEN
FORTY ONE MODERATOR. GIVE ME
JUST A MOMENT HERE IS ONE ZERO.
ACTUALLY HERE JUST A MOMENT.
THANK YOU TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS MARK PALMER GEO THE
SAN DIEGO MILITARY ADVISORY
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF S.
B. TEN FORTY ONE A BILL BY PRO
CAMMACK INTO WILL REALLY HELP
OUR MILITARY FAMILIES HAS A
STRUGGLE IN OUR- COMMAND ECONOMY
THANK YOU. THE CURRENT PLAN FOR
THEIR ISSUE ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME
BACK FOR OPPOSITION OF SB TEN
FORTY ONE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO TEN FORTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THERE ARE COUPLES. AND
CURRENTLY MANAGE YOU ALL RIGHT
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF TEN
FORTY ONE THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB TEN FORTY ONE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON THE TEN
SEVENTY FOUR BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
YARDLEY TO REQUIRE ON CANNABIS
EXCISE TAX IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND SB
TEN SEVENTY FOUR. ARE YOU COMING
UP ON THIS ONE- IN OPPOSITION
OKAY SO WE HAVE SUPPORT OF TEN
SIT BACK TO TEN SEVENTY FOUR
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF TEN SEVEN
FOUR. PRESS ONE TWO SUPPORT.
CURRENTLY MANAGE YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION OF TEN
SEVENTY FOUR COMMA THE REQUESTED
PRIMARY- TESTIMONY AGAINST SURE-
GOOD MORNING CENTERS MY NAME IS
COLONEL FERGUSON I'M THE
SECRETARY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WAS GONNA
COMMITTEE- SB SENSITIVE FOR
PLACES UNDUE ECONOMIC BURDEN ON
THE RETAIL PORTION THAT OF THE
KIND OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN THE
BILL ATTEMPTS TO MAKE REVENUE
NEUTRAL CHANGES IN CALIFORNIA'S
CANNABIS TAX STRUCTURE REPLACING
THE REVENUE WHICH WOULD BE LOST
BY THE ELIMINATION OF THE
CULTIVATION TAX WITH REVENUE
GENERATED BY A PROPORTIONAL
INCREASE THE STATE EXCISE TAX.
THIS AMOUNT WOULD BE DETERMINED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ANNUALLY THAT IS THE UNDUE AND
VERY COSTLY ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN PLACED ON THE PUBLIC
BOARD THE ADMINISTRATION WILL BE
TASKED WITH CALCULATING A TAX
INCREASE THE BY CONGRESS FIND AT
THIS BILL AS IN ADEQUATE METHODS
AND PROVIDE NECESSARY TAX RELIEF
TO THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ADDITIONALLY CANNABIS RETAILERS
AND CONSUMERS WILL BECOME THE
PARTY'S TWIST ECONOMIC BURDEN IS
PLACED UPON. HIS INCOME OF ANY
BILL WHICH SEEKS TO PROVIDE TAX
RELIEF DO SO IN A WAY THAT'S NOT
INCREASE THE COST OF THE
CONSUMER. OTHERWISE TAX
INEFFICIENT. I WAS BUILT SINCE.
REVENUE NEUTRAL INCREASE THE X.
TAX REPORTS THE REVENUE. MEDICAL
TO. THIS BILL BASICALLY OF MY-
SUPPLY AND THE EXCISE TAXES WELL
ABOVE THE OPTIMAL TAX RATE. IS
INDICATED BY THE DIMINISHING
MARGINAL RETURNS. BY CABS
RETAILERS THEREFORE INCREASING
THE EXCISE TAX ANY FURTHER.
DISTORTS THE PRESENT CANNABIS IN
THE LONG RUN IT WILL LEAD TO
LESS CONSUMPTION. A HIGHER RATE
OF UNEMPLOYMENT FROM DECREASED
REVENUE- THE BY CONGRESS HIGHLY
. AND THAT SORRY THE BLACK
CAUCUS FUNDS. EXIT NO VOTE ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
. MY ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION. TO
TEN SEVENTY FOUR. PLEASE PRESS.
ZERO TO. CURRENTLY NINE Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TEN SEVENTY
FOUR SINGLE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL SEND THAT TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE WILL BE ON S.
B. TWELVE TWENTY NINE BY SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER MCGUIRE ON
MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE GRANT
PROGRAM IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF TWELVE
TWENTY NINE THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM MODERATORS OR ANY
SUPPORT. FOR TWELVE TWENTY NINE.
HE'S PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
. GETTING ONE ZERO TO SUPPORT
WITH ONLINE SEVENTY. MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE'RE
PLEASED TO BE COUNTED AMONG
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT WHEN THE
TIME COMES. THANK YOU NEXT. AN
EXTRA LINE ONE TWENTY. THOUSANDS
OF THE DEPRESSION AND BIPOLAR
SUPPORT ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. CURRENTLY NINE
FURTHER IN Q. OKAY LET'S PULL
THE SAME PROCEDURE WITH THE
OPPOSITION I SEE WE HAVE. MISS
KRYSTAL WOULD LIKE TO. OPPOSE
THIS BILL ON FISCAL MATTERS ON
TWELVE TWENTY NINE PLEASE COME
FORWARD. REMEMBER YEAH THANK YOU
SENATOR PER CASKEY- GROUNDS-
RESTRICTIVE AND- THESE ARE ALSO
TARGETING AREAS OF WALDRON AND-
YOUTH WITH HI. FIRST CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCE SCORES. SO MY MAIN-
OPPOSITION CONCERN IS- AGAIN
THAT THE FOLKS. THAT FOR
FOMENTING A CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA
A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS ARE-
SEEKING SUSTAINABLE FUNDING FOR
THEMSELVES AND YET RESTRICTOR
GRANT FUNDING FOR A BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. INTERNS AND SYSTEM DO
YOU DO YOU DISPUTE THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIOD THAT DID THAT
WERE ESTIMATING IT'S GOING TO BE
FOR THE NINE HUNDRED NINE
THOUSAND TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM THOSE ARE SORT OF
CONSTANTS HERE YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THE SIZE OF THE GRANTS AND THE-
HOW MANY APPLICANTS WOULD GET
THOSE SITES AGAINST FIGHT LIMIT
HALF BY CAPPING IT. SO I I'M I'M
COMFORTABLE WITH WITH THE
APPLICANTS RECEIVING THE GRANTS
I JUST- I'M JUST SEEING A LARGER
THING AT PLAY THAT THAT THEY'RE
STILL- ET. YEAR YOU HAVE SO MUCH
MONEY WHY ARE WE GIVING THEM
WARY REQUIRING THEM TO. REPAY
SOME OF THIS MONEY TO PARENTS
FOR ENOUGH ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
ARE. HUNDRED TWO WE HAVE OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY REMOTELY IN
OPPOSITION OF A TWELVE TWENTY
NINE SB TWELVE POINT NINE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME SO. CURRENTLY MANY Q. OKAY
THE- MEMBERS SEEING THEIR
COMMENTS THANK YOU WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. TWELVE TWENTY
NINE IS MOVE THIS IS SPENCER
FILE LET'S MOVE TO JORDAN LEADER
MAGUIRE'S NEXT BILL S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN WHICH IS A
SUSPENSE CAN THAT THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATION US WHO WILL
MOVE RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY- FOR ANYBODY WISHING
TO- TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. I HAVE
MISS KRYSTAL AGAIN LISTED ON AS
IN SUPPORT ON THIS. PLEASE COME
FORWARD. THANK YOU SENATOR. SO I
EARLY I DO BELIEVE THIS IS A-
FOR GOOD USE OF FUNDS WITH WITH
THE AMENDMENTS- PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE PSYCHOSIS IS RECOVERABLE
IN I AM GRATEFUL TO SEE THAT THE
OVERSIGHT ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION WILL BE- HOPEFULLY RE
EMPOWERED IN CALIFORNIA TO- WORK
WITH HEALTHY- TO HELP RECOVER.
ARE SIDE ON AGENCIES THAT WAS
HAPPENED ON PURPOSE- SO. IT IS.
YEAH AND JUST I MEAN IT JUST
AGAIN THAT THIS. SO ANYWAY I'M
I'M I'M GRATEFUL AND YOU CAN YOU
SEE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE IT SEEMS
LIKE IT TEARS FOUR POINT ONE
FIVE NEW INDIVIDUALS WORKING ON
THIS PROBLEM THIS YEAR THREE
POINT ONE NEXT YEAR THREE POINT
THREE AND TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE AND IN THREE POINT THREE
AND TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX WHAT
SAID IT SEEMED APPEARS TO BE A
NATURAL BUILDUP OF STAFF AND
EXPENDITURE OF FUNDS. TO ADDRESS
THE COORDINATED SPECIALTY CARE.
YOU'RE AAND I'M AND I'M
GRATEFUL THAT THERE ARE. HER
RECENT CONTACT WITH TO PARTNER
MANAGED HEALTH CARE PARTICULARLY
DR KELLY PFEIFER- SO BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THEY WERE SILENT IN MY
OPINION TOO SO- SO YEAH IF OUR
AGENCIES ARE WORKING TOGETHER
UNDERSTAND. WHAT'S WORKING
WHAT'S NOT BEEN WORKING THEN
THAT THAT'S THAT'S A GOOD THING
AND AS FAR AS THOSE PARTICULAR
NUMBERS CENTER AND NOT- THAT
WERE THOSE THE NUMBER OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKER CODE-
FULL TIME- STATIC WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE CDI CDI ESTIMATES IS
GOING TO BE FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS THIS YEAR AND SIXTEEN
THOUSAND TO REVIEW THE FILING
WHEN THE PLANS ARE UPDATED. THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. AGENCY OUR ESTIMATES
AND UNKNOWN CONTRACT COSTS- TO
COMMISSION TO STUDY AND THEN- MH
SO AC ESTIMATES ARE UNDETERMINED
AT THIS LIMITED COSTS LOW
POTENTIAL PROBABLY HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS SO MOST OF THE ACTION
IS GOING TO BE WITH DM HC. AND
SPREAD OVER A FOUR YEAR PERIOD.
HI AND CAN THEIR- THE CITY UP
THEN CAN THERE. HI THANK YOU.
ANY ELSE WHICH CONTEST ROOM.
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. MARY LYNN I
WILLIAMS- OF THE COUPLES FOR
FREE TO THE SERGEANT WRITER WILL
GIVE IT HERE WHAT WILL THEY GO
INTO THE FILE OR TO THE SENATORS
. INTO THE FILE. FOR ME TO GO
THE- OKAY YEAH THAT'S OKAY THE
BILL NONSTOP OKAY THANK YOU
LET'S MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU'LL PLEASE PROMPT THOSE
WAITING TO TESTIFY AND S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN. I CALL
THEM FORWARD. PRESS ONE DIRECTOR
TIME. GET ONE ZERO WE CAN. ALLOW. ONE EIGHT. WITHOUT DOES LINE.
ONE TWENTY. THIS IS FALSE OF IT
BIPOLAR ALLIANCE IS OF THIS BILL. OKAY GOT BACK HERE TO Y.
TWENTY EIGHT. CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE THIS POLICE ON
THE HOW OF THE CAL STATUS
PSYCHO- THIS BILL SAY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA A LOT OF MONEY.
OVER THE NEXT TEN OR TWENTY
YEARS THANK YOU OR YOUR AYE VOTE
NO SUSPENSE. IN LINE. ONE TWENTY
NINE. DANIEL KIM- REVEREND
DANIEL KIM CHAIR OF INTERFAITH
SOLIDARITY NETWORK ARE YOU SEEM
LIKE I. MR THE DEBATE ON THE S.
B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX HE SHUT
DOWN EARLY SO CANYON- IT HASN'T
COME UP YET THAT'S LATER ON. WE
HAVE GOT TO CENTER STERN DOES
HIS. PART IT. MODERATOR NESS
THIS IS SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN. SHARE AND LOCAL LAD
CAROLINE. FORTY NINE. FORTY NINE
YEAR OPEN. AND I DON'T UP YOUR
METER. YOU'LL GO AHEAD. AND AN
MRI OWN LINE FORTY NINE I'M NOT
SURE. OKAY YES I'M NOT FOUND
THEM BECAUSE- CAN IN- THROUGH TO
APPROVE IT THANK YOU. MAX AND
THEN PREPARING ALL RIGHT LET'S
HEARD FROM SUPPORTERS WILL FALL
SAME PER SE FROM IS ANYBODY IN
ROME TWENTY TWO HUNDRED- WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY OR SPEAK IN. IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTY THIRTY
SEVEN SEEING NONE- MODERATE
LEADERS MOVED TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IN
OPPOSITION TO. SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN FIVE ACQUIRE. THE
POST PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS. MINUTES. ONE ZERO. AND
CURRENTLY NONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE DAYS
I DON'T SEE ANY QUESTIONS. FROM
MY COLLEAGUES HERE THANK YOU
EVERYBODY WITHOUT OBJECTION S.
B. THIRTEEN THIRTY SEVEN- WILL
BE MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
NEXT ITEM UP IS S. B. R. TEN
SEVENTY FIVE BY SENDER SCANNER
WHICH IS DISPENSED CANDID CENTER
SKINNER HAS WE PRESENTATION SO
WE'LL MOVE RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIFY I DON'T SEE ANY LEADS
FOR THE FOR WITH LIKE MINDED
GONNA OF THE STATE BUILDING
TRADE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MISTER ROGERS. FIVE OTHERS IN
ROOM TWO. TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO MAKE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
QUESTION A TESTIFIED BEER OUR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MODERATE
IF YOU PLEASE PROP ANYBODY WITH.
WHEN TO TESTIFY ON THIS BE TEN
SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU PLEASE
PRESS ONE THERE AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IT'S. ONE ZERO. GIVE ME
JUST A MOMENT BUT IF YOU IF YOU
HEAR. LINE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FIVE FEET OF WATER WITH
LIKE A VALLEY INDUSTRY AND
COMMERCE ASSOCIATION AND WE
SUPPORT SB TEN SEVENTY FIVE
THANK. IN LINE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THREE NINE. FOUR
NINE YOUR OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. SORRY BOUT ONE MORE HERE
HOLDING CAN BE CONFIRMED BECAUSE
NEXT ONE. SURE SECOND HERE THERE
WITH AN OPERATOR HERE. AND
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI I'M I'M SORRY I YEAR I TOLD
EARLIER I THINK THAT I GAVE MY
SUPPORT FOR THE WRONG BILL AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A WAY I
CAN CHANGE THAT. WHICH BILL ARE
YOU CALLING ON. I'M WELL I DON'T
KNOW WHAT BILL ENDED UP GIVING
MY SUPPORT FOR. BUT THE ONE THAT
I WANTED TO GIVE MY SUPPORT FOR
WITH SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX. WE
HAVEN'T GOT TO THE FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX IS PLEASE. STAY ON.
OKAY WELL WE HAVEN'T WE IT'S
TOWARDS THE END OF THE CALENDAR
. ALREADY ANYBODY ELSE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TEN SEVENTY FIVE
BY SKINNER ON HYDROGEN GREEN
HYDROGEN. THANK YOU OKAY LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCEDURES IN
THERE WE DIDN'T THAT- WITH THE
OPPOSITION CERVIDAE HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WISHING TO
OPPOSE SB TEN SEVENTY FIVE
SEEING NONE MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE GO TO TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE THANK YOU UP IN ANY
WITNESSES WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
TEN SEVENTY FIVE. SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
CURRENTLY NONE IN Q. VERY GOOD
WILL CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING- BRING
AFFECTED DISTANCE HIMSELF FROM
MY COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
EVERYBODY WITHOUT OBJECTION S.
B. AT TEN SEVENTY FIVE IS MOVED
TO THE SUSPENSE ACCOUNT UNDER-
THE NEXT ITEM IS S. B. ELEVEN OH
ONE BY CAT CENTRE COVER YEAR
WHICH IS DISPENSED CANDIDATE THE
AUTHOR HAS WE PRESENTATIONS WILL
MOVE RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC.
TESTIMONY ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MIKE MADIGAN
GET THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
THIS IS ONE OF OUR SPONSORED
BILLS- SUPPORT THANK YOU. MISTER
MONACAN ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MODERATOR LET'S MOVE TO THE
PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF. S. B. ELEVEN OH ONE
OF THE OUR TELECONFERENCE
SERVICES FEUD PROMPT THEM-
PLEASE PROCEED. CHECK OUT AGAIN
IT'S ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. THIS
PRESS ONE ZERO WE CAN GO TO LINE
FORTY NINE. YES SIGN IN SUPPORT
UNDER THOMPSON POWER MAIL TO
SUPPORT OF THE LEVEL ONE. THANK
YOU. NEXT. THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME HEARTLESS FOR THE SAME
PROCEDURE FOR THE OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED LIKE TO.
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE OF IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. ELEVEN A ONE
C. NINE NOTING THAT NONE THE
FORMALLY LET'S GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MODERATOR
IS- ANY WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION THE S. B.
ELEVEN OH ONE PLEASE CALL THEM
FORWARD. PLEASE PRESS ONE THERE
AT THIS TIME. AND CLEANING Q.
OKAY CLOSE PUBLIC CARE BRING
AFFECTED TO IS SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITH MY COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU EVERYONE WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. ELEVEN A ONE IS
MOVED TO SUSPENSE FILED NEXUS A
LETTER S. B. ELEVEN OH NINE ALSO
BY CENTER CABALLERO IT IS THIS
WHICH IS A SUSPENSE CANDID THE
AUTHORS WAVE- PRESENTATION SO
WE'LL MOVE RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC-
HERE AT THOSE IN SUPPORT OF.
ELEVEN SB ELEVEN APPLE NINE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIR CHRISTMAS
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
AND MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANY'S
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
ELEVEN OH NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RESPECT OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. ELEVEN OH NINE. ARTLESS
MOVED TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WITH A TEST FIND SUPPORT OF S.
B. ELEVEN OH NINE. VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OVER SMARTER IF
YOU'LL PLEASE PROP THOSE.
WISHING TO TESTIFY. PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO FIVE FIFTY NINE. IT
WILL GO NEXT- THE FIRST CAROLINE
FORTY NINE. AND THE TAKEN TO
SELF SANTIAGO TO LINE SIXTY SIX
. THE INTERNET IS JUST A MOMENT
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMPOSED COALITION IN SUPPORT OF
IT NINE NINE THANK YOU. ENRICO
FACT NOT ALIGNED FORTY NINE. ON
A CONSTANT ARE MALE IS SUPPORT
OF ELEVEN ON THEM THANK YOU. AND
IS CURRENTLY MEANT FOR THEIR
ISSUE ALL RIGHT LET'S FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCEDURE FOR OPPOSITION OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
WHICH IN THE TESTIFIED
OPPOSITION OF S. B. ELEVEN OH
NINE SEEING NONE MODERATOR LET'S
MOVE TO THE- THOSE. MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WE NEED TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION VIA THE-
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE TO S. B.
ELEVEN OH NINE PLEASE. CALL THEM
. ORDERED PLEASE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. CAN IT'S
ONE ZERO. AND CURRENTLY NOT IN
Q. ALMOST CLOSE PUBLICAR BRING
BACK TODAY SAYING NO HANDS THANK
YOU EVERYBODY WITHOUT OBJECTION
S. B. ELEVEN OH NINE IN
CALIFORNIA RENEWABLES PORTFOLIO
STANDARDS PROGRAM AND BIOENERGY
PROJECTS IS MOVED TO DISPENSE
CALENDAR THE NEXT ITEM IS S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE BY CENTER
COPPER EURO AND RESILIENCE
NAVIGATORS PROGRAM CLIMATE
CHANGE RESILIENCE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS AND IT IS A
CANDIDATE FOR. ASSIST THE
SUSPENSE FILE THE AUTHORS WAVE
TEST PRESENTATION SO WE'LL MOVE
RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY WE
DON'T HAVE ANY OF FORMAL OF
WITNESSES AND SUPPORTS A AND
NOBODY HERE MOVING. TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THIS IS RITA. COME
FORWARD SO MODERATOR WILL MOVE
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WAITED
TESTIFYING SUPPORT VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IF YOU
WILL PLEASE PROMPT THOSE WISHING
TO. SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND IT'S ONE ZERO FOR
SMOKING GOT A LINE FORTY NINE.
ON A CONSTANT CARMEL IN SUPPORT
OF ELEVEN TWENTY THREE THANK YOU
. AND CURRENTLY NONE FURTHER AND
- OKAY HAVING HER FROM THE
SUPPORTERS AS FALL THE SAME
PROCEDURE FROM ANY OPPOSITION I
DO NOT SEE ANYBODY HERE ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WE WANTED TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF. S. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE SO MODERATOR
LET'S MOVE TO THOSE WITNESSES
WERE IN THE TESTIFIED VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR PERCENT
OPPOSITION TO S. B. ELEVEN
TWENTY NINE PLEASE CALL THEM.
THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY NINE Q.
I WAS CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
AFFECTED THIS SINGLE- COLLEAGUES
WHICH IN THIS. SPEAK ON THIS
MATTER WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE IS MOVED AS
A SUSPENSE FILE NEXT UP IS S. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE BY CENTER
COUPLE YEAR ON LIABILITY CLAIMS
TIME LIMIT DEMANDS IT IS A
SUSPENSE CAN THAT THE AUTHOR IS
WAY PRESENTATION SO WE'LL MOVE
RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
FOR ANYBODY. WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED SAYING THAT
MODERATOR LET'S MOVE TO- THOSE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. S. B.
ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ADMIN AN-
INDIVIDUALLY TO- TO SPEAK. AGAIN
IT'S ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY MANY Q. OKAY LET'S
MOVE FROM THE THERE IS A SUPPORT
TO THE OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED WHICH IN THE SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
FIVE BY CAP EURO I SEEN ON FILM
MODERATOR LET'S MOVE TO THOSE
WITNESSES WAY TO TESTIFY THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IN
OPPOSITION TO. S. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY FIVE AND CALL THEM FORWARD
INDIVIDUAL. THANK YOU PRESS. ONE
ZERO FIFTY FIVE. THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. IT'S CLOSE PUBLIC
AFFECTED THEIR SEE NO QUESTIONS
THANK YOU EVERYONE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB ELEVEN FIFTY FIVE
THIS MOVE THE SUSPENSE COUNTERED
NEXT UP IS S. B. FOURTEEN TEN BY
KAPPA EURO THE CALIFORNIA IN
COURT ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT
TRANSPORTATION IMPACTS WHICH IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WITH PRESENTATIONS WILL MOVE
RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC TEST MY FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED- WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WAITING
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
L. SERVICE MORE IF YOU PROP
THOSE WE WISHING TO TESTIFYIN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FOURTEEN TEN.
CAVALEIRO THANK YOU TO SUPPORT
THANK YOU TO SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. I AM CURRENTLY
LEARNING QUEUE OKAY HAVE YOU
HEARD FROM SUPPORTERS CISCO OF
THE OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
QUESTION TEST FOR IN OPPOSITION
S. B. FOURTEEN TENSING THEN
MODERATE LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICES FOR ANY
WITNESSES WHICH IN THE TESTIFIED
TO THE COMMITTEE. IN OPPOSITION
OF S. B. FOURTEEN TEN PLEASE
CALL THEM INDIVIDUALLY. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. IT
CURRENTLY NINE IN Q. THANK YOU
ARE WILL CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
FOR TRYING TO DISSING THE HOPE-
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FOURTEEN TEN IS MOVE THE
SUSPENSE FILE NEXUS S. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX BY CENTER
COVER EURO ON CANNABIS WATER
POLLUTION CRIMES WHICH IS AKIN
TO THAT. OF FOR THE SUSPENSE
FILE THE AUTHORS WE PRESENTATION
SO MOVE RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIFY I SEE NO ONE HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WISH TO
TESTIFY SO MODERATOR LET'S MOVE
TO THE- MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING TO TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT
VIA TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IF
YOU'LL PLEASE PROMPT THEM
INDIVIDUALLY TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF. FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX
BY CABALLERO. IF I PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAINST ONE
ZERO. WE CAN GO FIRST TO LINE
FORTY NINE. HI YES I'M NOT TOM
THEN EMAIL I'M IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX THANK YOU. I
AM CURRENTLY NINE FURTHER IN Q.
ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE TO
OPPOSITION OF. SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY SIX I DON'T SEE ANYONE
HERE IN ROOMS- TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SO MODERATE LET'S MOVE
TO THOSE. MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX
WILL BE OUR TELECONFERENCE
SERVICES WE PLEASE CALL THEM
FORWARD INDIVIDUALLY. PLEASE
PRESS ONE DIRECTORS TIME. HE
CURRENTLY LEARNING QUEUE OKAY
WILL CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING BACK
TO DISSING THE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
SIX HE'S MOVED HIS SPENCE FILE
NEXT UP WE HAVE S. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR- PORCHES WE
SEE SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION THROUGH
MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC HEARING-
TEST MY FOR ANYBODY WISHING TO.
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT
. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO DEFINES
. SEVEN MODERATELY SEE NO ONE
HERE LET'S GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCES SERVICES AND SEE
IF ANYBODY IS WHICH IN THE SUIT
TESTIFIED SUPPORT OF SB. ELEVEN
EIGHTEEN. YES ONE ZERO. AND
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NONE LET'S FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCEDURE FOR THOSE AND
WISHING TO BE HEARD IN
OPPOSITION IF ANYBODY HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WITH
LIKE TO OPPOSE SB ELEVEN
EIGHTEEN PLEASE COME FOR LIKE
MONEY GOING TO BE AT THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK RESPOND AGAIN SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MODERATOR
LET'S GO TO THE TELECOM SERVICE
AND PLEASE PROMPT ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
SB ELEVEN EIGHTEEN BY BORCHERS.
THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIRECTORS TIME. THANK YOU CAN
CLOSE PUBLIC CAMPING AFFECTED
DISSING THE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTEEN
IS MOVE THE SUSPENSE FILE- NEXT
ITEM IS S. B. TWELVE SIXTY SIX
BY SEVEN REPORTERS ON INCOME TAX
CREDITS- DESIGNATED WILD FIRES
ZONE IS A SUSPENSE CANDID THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO WE
MOVE RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED I SEE NONE
MODERATOR. WE PLEASE. S. OR
PROMPT ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING ON A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE REFLECTED- THIS. ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWELVE SIXTY SIX I'M CENTER
BORCHERS. PLEASE PRESS ONE
CHARACTERS KIND OF SLOW. AGAIN
ONE ZERO. AND CURRENTLY NINE Q.
ART BEFORE HAVING HEARD FROM THE
SUPPORTERS THIS FALL THE SAME
PROCEDURE FOR THE OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED AND WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS THIS IN OPPOSITION OF S.
B. TWELVE SIXTY SIXTEEN NONE-
LET'S MOVE TO THE ANY WITNESSES
WHEN THE TEST BY FEAR A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MODERATOR
FEW PLEASE PROMPT. INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF S. B. TWELVE SIXTY SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE DIRECTORS TIME. AND THEN Q. CURRENTLY CLOSE
PUBLIC HEARING BRING AFFECTED
THIS SEEING NO HANDS UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. TWELVE SIXTY SIX
IS MOVE THE SUSPENSE FILE. OUR
NEXT BILL IS SB ELEVEN NINETEEN
BY SUNDERLAND THE MON ON PUBLIC
UTILITIES GAS CORPORATIONS GAS
PLANTS NEW CONSTRUCTION OR
SUBSTANTIAL MODIFICATION THIS
MATTER IS A SUSPENSE CANDID THE
AUTHORS WE PRESENTATION SO MOVE
RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
FOR ANYBODY. WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT C. NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MODERATOR IF THERE ARE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. ELEVEN NINETEEN A CENTER
LAMONT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE OR
FIRST PLEASE PROMPT. THEM AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY
RUNNING Q. SEEING FIVE
EXHAUSTING THE SUPPORTERS OF THE
OPPOSITION OR ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED IN OPPOSITION TO THE
SP ELEVEN NINETEEN BY CENTER
LAMONT IS SENATOR MIKE MONEY CAN
BE KEPT STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION. THANKS VERY MUCH
SEEING THEIR WHETHER MEMBERS
PUBLIC MODERATOR LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELECONFERENCE RIVERS OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
ELEVEN NINETEEN- PLEASE CALL
THEM FORWARD INDIVIDUALLY. IF
YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IS SO. THANK EARLY NINETEEN KIDS
CLOTHES FIVE CARE BRING BACK
TODAY SEEING THEIR HANDS UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION S. B. ELEVEN
NINETEEN IS MOVE THE SUSPENSE
FILE. NOW WE HAVE S. ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE MY CENTER LAMONT
REGARDING EMPLOYMENT SALARIES
AND WAGES THIS IS SUSPENSE CAL
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO
LET'S MOVE TO THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING TO. I SEE NO MEMBERS
OF PUBLIC YOUR ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED WISHING TO TESTIFY
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE PROP
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. ELEVEN SIXTY TWO. THE
MORNING CALL THEM FORWARD
INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU AGAIN
IT'S ONE ZERO TWO- YOU CAN. SHOW
YOUR SUPPORT YES ONE ZERO. THANK
YOU. NINE THANK YOU OKAY NOT A
KEYLESS MOVES THE OPPOSITION
NOBODY HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED IS COMING FORWARD TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO SO MODERATE
LIST PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WITH THE TESTIFYING OPPOSITION
THE S. B. ELEVEN OF SIXTY TWO
AND CALL THEM. FORWARD THANK YOU
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. YOU CAN FIRST CAROLINE
FORTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON PETER
WATER WITH BIKE- VALLEY INDUSTRY
AND COMMERCE ASSOCIATION AND WE
OPPOSED SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO
THANKS THANK YOU. EXTRA LINE.
FIFTY FIVE. I NEED A COMPULSORY
Q. AT CERTAIN- WENT FURTHER IN
Q. HEARTLESS CLOSE PUBLIC CARE
BRING BACK TO THIS SCENE NO HAN
STEP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO WAS MOVED TO SUSPENSE
FILE. S. B. ABOUT TWELVE THIRTY
BY CENTER LIMÓN ON. ZERO
EMISSION AND THEIR EMISSION
VEHICLES INCENTIVE PROGRAM
REQUIREMENT THIS IS SUSPENSE CAN
THAT THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION TO MOVE RIGHT TO A
PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR ANYBODY
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWELVE THIRTY SEEING THOUGH
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC YEAR ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATE WILL
MOVE TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
SERVICES AND PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF. S. B. TWELVE
THIRTY- AND CALL THEM UP
INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
INCREMENTING CUE BALL I WOULD
HAVE HERE WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
IAGO CRYSTALLINE FORTY NINE. YES
ANOTHER TIME SANSKAR MAIL I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS MEASURE BUT I
ALSO WANTED TO BE IN SUPPORT OF
BAB BILL ELEVEN NINETEEN I WAS
NOT AVAILABLE TO PRESS THE-
THANK YOU WILL DO LEE NOTED.
OKAY THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT HERE
WITHOUT ONE MORE. AND WILL OPEN
LINE ONE THIRTY THREE. I THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- CHRIS THOMAS IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE THIRTY
THINK IT'S MONEY WELL SPENT
THANK YOU BYE BYE. AND THEN FOR
THEIR QUEUE AT THIS TIME LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCEDURE
PROPOSITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED- WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWELVE
THIRTY SEEING NINE MODERATE
ELLIS MOVED TO TELECONFERENCE
RVERS. IF YOU COULD PLEASE PROP
ANY INDIVIDUALS TO THE PUBLIC
WHICH THE TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWELVE
THIRTY. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
METALINK QUEUE AT THIS TIME OKAY
LET'S CLOSE PUBLIC CAMPING BACK
TODAY SAYING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION S. B. TWELVE
THIRTY IS MOVE THE SUSPENSE FILE
S. B. ELEVEN FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR ROTH ACUTE CARE
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL LOAN FUND
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION SO
MOVE. DIRECTLY TO THE PUBLIC
TESTING FOR ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT SENIOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MODERATE
WILL MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY V. ARE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE CAN YOU
PLEASE PROMPT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. ELEVEN FORTY THREE. CALL
THEM UP INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND THEN A QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE THE
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYBODY HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF S. B. ELEVEN FORTY THREE
SEEING NONE MODERATOR LET'S MOVE
TO TELECONFERENCE SERVICE YOU
PLEASE. PROP MEMBERS SAID. THE
PUBLIC INDIVIDUALLY WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION SB ELEVEN
FORTY THREE. OKAY AND AGAIN IT'S
ONE ZERO. DO WE BELIEVE WE HAVE
A CARRYOVER FROM THE FROM THE
SUPPORT WILL GO AHEAD AND OPEN
THAT LINE IT CLAIMED FORTY NINE.
YES MAIL I MEAN CONTRACT BECAUSE
- YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
THEN FURTHER AFTER FINE OKAY
THIS CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING BACK
TODAY SEEING NO HANDS UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. ELEVEN FORTY
THREE HIS MOVE TO DISPENSE
COUNTER SB ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE
BY CENTER GROVE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LIBRARY STATE WIDE
IMAGINATION LIBRARY PROGRAM IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS
WAY PRESENTATIONS WILL MOVE
RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
FOR ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY%
IN SUPPORT I SEE NO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HEARING ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED QUESTION TEST VICE A
MODERATOR. IF YOU PLEASE WITH
PROMPT THOSE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE B. R.
TELECONFERENCE SERVICING CALL
THEM UP INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. HEARTLESS
FALL THE SAME PROCEDURE FOR THE
OPPOSITION SEEING THOUGH MEMBERS
HERE IN THE PUBLIC IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IN WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION LET'S GO
BACK TO MODERATOR ON OUR
TELECONFERENCE- VERSUS AND
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TESTIFIED OPPOSITION TO
S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE. AND
CALL THEM FORWARD INDIVIDUALLY.
CERTAINLY AGAINST. ONE ZERO.
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. LET'S CLOSE
PUBLIC CARE BRING BACK TO THE
TASTING THE HANDS UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE
IS MOVE THE SUSPENSE FILE. S. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY CENTER
GROVE WRITTEN REGARDS INCOME
TAXES CREDITS QUALIFIED FIRST
YEAR WAGES FOSTER AND FORMER
FOSTER. YOUTH IS A SPEND COUNTY
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATIONS WILL
MOVE RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF. S. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FORCING THE
MEMBERS HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED MODERATE WILL MOVE TO.
TO THOSE WAITING TESTIFYING
SUPPORT FEAR TELECONFERENCING
HISSES IF YOU'LL PLEASE PROMPT.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. IN
INDIVIDUALLY. IS WISHING
TESTIFYING SB. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR. THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND THEN IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME PART WILL
MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION ON THIS
ON THIS MATTER I SEE NO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR MODERATOR
IF YOU'LL PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WILLING TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR FEAR TELECONFERENCE
REVERSING CALL THEM FORD
INDIVIDUALLY. PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIRECTORS TIME. AND CURRENTLY
NINETY Q. OKAY WELL LET'S CLOSE
PUBLIC CAMPING AFFECTED THIS I
SEE NO HAN STEP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR IS MOVE THE SUSPENSE
COUNTER SB ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
BUT CENTER COM LACQUER ON FABRIC
RECYCLING A PILOT PROJECT GROUP
PROGRAM BUSINESSES BEEN SCANNED
AT THE AUTHORS WE PRESENTATION
SO WE WILL MOVE RIGHT TO THE
PUBLIC TEST BY BRITISH ENGLISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. WHICH
IS. TESTIFYING SUPPORT TO
MODERATE IF WE CAN IF WE CAN
MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHEN THE TEST FIND SUPPORT VR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE AND IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THEM
INDIVIDUALLY. IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN THEM.
PLEASE CALL THEM FORWARD.
CERTAINLY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND LEGAL LINE
FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD- SEND
OUR MAIL IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
ANYTHING ESPECIALLY FIVE CALLING
ON ALL THAT THANK YOU. AND
CURRENTLY KNOWN FOR THEIR QUEUE
I LET'S MOVE FALL THE SAME
PROCEDURE FOR THE OPPOSITION I
SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
WISHING TO. TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN MODERATOR IF YOU'LL
PLEASE MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. AND OPPOSITION FEAR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE AND CALL
THEM FORWARD INDIVIDUAL THIS IS
S. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN COM
LOCKER. THANK YOU AND PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TWELVE POLLS.
EIGHTY NINE IN Q. NONE OKAY UGH
THAT'S BECAUSE PUBLIC HEARING
PROTECTED DANCING THOUGH- HANDS
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN IS MOVE THE
SUSPENSE FIRE FILE S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE BY CENTER
COMPLEX- THAT PRESCRIPTION DRUG
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS CARSHARING
PHARMACY. BENEFIT MANAGERS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDID THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION HOUSE WILL MOVE
DIRECTLY TO THE PUBLIC TEST WAY
FOR ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME FORWARD.
FIELDING GRIEVES BY AKON
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU ACCENT THING NO OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
MODERATOR LET'S MOVE TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WE NEED
HAS FIND SUPPORT. OF S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IF YOU
PLEASE PROMPT THEM INDIVIDUALLY.
AND CALL THEM FORWARD. THANK YOU
PLEASE PRESS ONE DIRECTOR FINE.
IT CURRENTLY LEARNING QUEUE OKAY
WAS ONLY THAT ONE HERE GIVE ME
JUST A MOMENT. GIVE ME JUST A
MOMENT HERE.
ONE ONE THIRTY TWO. YES BY DVSA
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT EXCELLENT
ANYONE ELSE MODERATOR. CURRENTLY
NINETY TWO PORTALS FLOW TO THE
OPPOSITION- AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED WHICH THAT TESTIFY IN A
POSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
ONE SEEING NONE MODERATOR LET'S
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. WHO
WANT TO TEST FIVE VR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE AND IF
YOU PLEASE PROMPT THEM
INDIVIDUALLY WHO WANT TESTIFIED
IN OPOSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. CLOSE PUBLIC
PRACTICING THEIR HANDS UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY ONE IS WITH THE SUSPENSE
FILE SB TWELVE SEVENTEEN BY
CENTER ALLEN THIS IS STATE
REGIONAL COLLABORATIVE FOR
CLIMATE EQUITY RESILIENCE IN
THIS IS SPENCER CAN THAT THE
AUTHORS WE PRESENTATION SO MOVE
RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC TEST ME FOR
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT I SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. MODERATOR IF YOU WILL
PLEASE MOVE TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC POINT TEST FIVE YEAR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IMPROMPTU
THE LATE ON IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWELVE SEVENTEEN. THIS PRESS ONE
DIRECTORS TIME. CURRENTLY NINETY
Q. WILL FOLLOW SAME PROCEDURE
FOR OPPOSITION I SEE NO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HEARING ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IN OPPOSITION
OF SB TWELVE SEVENTEEN TO
MODERATOR FUEL PROP MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTEEN. EACH PRESS ONE ZERO
ACTORS TIME. WE GOT A LINE FORTY
NINE. ON A CONSTANT CURRENCY NOW
I'M SORRY BUT I WATCHED. A LOT
FOR IT IN ORDER TO GET THAT OFF-
PLEASE- IT. THANK YOU MARKET
PHYSICAL THIS IT THANK YOU OKAY
. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE TWELVE SEVENTEEN. CURRENTLY
NINETY Q. OKAY CLOSE PUBLIC
CAMPAIGN PRACTICING HAND SOAP
WITHOUT OBJECTION S. B. AT
TWELVE SEVENTEEN IS MOVED
DISPENSED COUNTER. NEXUS S. B.
1250% AROUND WHICH CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING THE OPERATED
VEHICLES WHICH IS A SUSPENSE
CANNOT THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION SO WE MOVE RIGHT TO
THE PUBLIC HEARING I SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE. IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. CUT TWELVE
FIFTY EIGHT SO MODERATOR LISTEN
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WE NEED
TESTIFIED SUPPORT VR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE IF YOU'LL
PLEASE PROP THEM INDIVIDUALLY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE FIFTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. OVERLYING
EIGHTY EFFECT. I REMEMBER HIS
NAME TO THE ELBOW AUTOMATICALLY
COMING AFFAIRS RECRUITING FOR
THE PRIMARY SPONSOR THE SELF
ASSEMBLED TALK TO BE ABLE TO
MEND THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM UNDER CHIEF THE IN ORDER
TO ALLOW FOR SPECIALLY MANAGED
ON THE VEHICLE PLEASE THE BULKY
COMPETE FOR THE FIRST P. P. FUND
BUT WE'RE CONFISCATE ANY
ADDITIONAL. REPUBLICAN WE ASK
YOUR SUPPORT. THE BILL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ANALYZE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M NOT TOM
CURRENCY NOW I WOULD SUPPORT OF
THE PEOPLE THANK YOU NEXT. AND
FURTHER IN Q. AT THE TIME I
LET'S MOVE THE OPPOSITION I SEE
NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WHICH IS
AS FAR IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
FIFTY SOME MODERATORS LET'S GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHICH
THE TESTIFIED VIA OUR
TELECONFERENCE A SERVICE TO
PLEASE PROMPT THEM INDIVIDUALLY
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF S.
B. TWELVE FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
TO OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND CURRENTLY
NINETY Q. CLOSE PUBLIC CAMPAIGN
BACK TO THIS IN THE HANDS OF
WITHOUT OBJECTION S. B. TWELVE
FIFTY EIGHT IS MOVED TO SUSPENSE
FILE S. B. TWELVE NINETY BY
CENTER ALAN ON SIDEWALK VENDORS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION TO MOVE
RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC HAS MY FOR
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT I SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. THE MODERATOR FOR YOU
PLEASE PROP MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC B. R. TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE WHO ELECTED TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE
NINETY. SIDLE VENDORS. PLEASE
PRESS ONE DIRECTOR TIME. YOU MAY
NOT ALIGN EIGHTY THREE. MISTER
KAREN MEMBERS OF THE US ELITES
JOHN WE HAVE THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA SPONSORING IN SUPPORT OF
THAT THE WHOLE NIGHT THANK YOU.
AND CURRENTLY NONE FURTHER IN Q.
FOUR SAME PROCEDURES FROM
POSITIONS UNIVERSAL PUBLIC
HEARING ROOM TWELVE TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. WE SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWELVE
NIACIN MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE
PROP WITNESSES. YOU'RE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE TO STORE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF S. B. TWELVE NINETEEN CALL
THE FORD INDIVIDUALLY. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT. WE CAN
OPEN LINE ONE THIRTY. CERVANTES
POPS OUT TO GO TO WASHINGTON I'M
ALL POVERTY WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL. NEXT MORE HERE GIVE
ME JUST A MOMENT TO SAY QUEUE UP
HERE SECOND. THE REASON I'M HERE. WE CAN GO TO LINE. ONE THIRTY
EIGHT. OKAY I'M GONNA MCCARTY
MEDICALLY OUR COLLECTIVE AND I A
FULL SB TWELVE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT LINE ONE FORTY. THREE
ESPINOZA FROM INCLUDED ACTION
CALLING IN OPPOSITION TO THE-
THANK YOU NECKS YEAH ONE THIRTY
NINE. MEDINA ON BEHALF OF
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS IN OPPOSITION TO ASK
BECAUSE NINETY. AND ONE HIT WE
GOT ONE MORE WITH AN OPERATOR.
THAT'S. WE JUST MOVED HERE OKAY.
MOTOR HAVE SOMEBODY ELSE IN LINE
. EVEN DO WE GET TO NOW- LINE.
ONE FORTY ONE. GO AHEAD ONE
FORTY ONE. YES THIS ONE IS NOT
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNCIL CALLING
IN OPPOSITION OF TWELVE NINETY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
INTERESTING. AND THEN PROVIDING
HERE OKAY THIS FOLLOW SAME
PROCEDURE FOR OPPOSITION SENIOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. IN I
KNOW THAT WAS CLOSE PUBLIC
HEARING BRING BACK TODAY SEEING
THEIR HANDS UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
S. B. TWELVE NINETY IS MOVED TO
SUSPENSE FILE NEXT UP IS S. B.
TWELVE FORTY SIX BY SENATOR
STERN ON INCOME TAXES GROSS
INCOME EXCLUSIONS FOR. WILDFIRE
IT IS A SUSPENSE KENNEDY AUTHORS
WE PRESENTATION SO WE MOVE RIGHT
TO THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE FORTY
SIX AS YOU KNOW MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING ROOM TWENTY ONE
TO TWO MODERATOR- IF YOU. WILL
PLEASE MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WIENER TESTS FIND SUPPORT
VR TELECONFERENCE ARVEST AND
PROMPT. THEM INDIVIDUALLY WHO
WANT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF
S. B. TWELVE FORTY SIX. THANK
YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. IN NINETEEN Q.
CURRENTLY OKAY LET'S GO TO THE
OPPOSITION IS OR ANYBODY.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED A SCENE THEN
LET'S GO TO THE BACK TO THE
TELECONFERENCE RVERS FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WE IN THE
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION S. B.
TWELVE FORTY SIX MODERATOR FEW
PLEASE CALL THEM FORD
INDIVIDUALLY. HE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY
NINE Q. CLOSE PUBLIC HEARING
BRING BACK TODAY SAYING NO HAN
STEP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWELVE
FORTY SIX IS MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE COUNTER NEXUS S. B.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX BY SENATOR
STERN STATE ENERGY RESOURCES
CONSERVATION DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION STRATEGIC PLAN
INTEGRATED ENERGY RESOURCES AND
POLICIES WHICH IS A SPEND
SCANNED IT THE AUTHORS WAVE.
PRESENTATION SO WE MOVE RIGHT TO
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR ANYBODY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX A
SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING ROOM TWENTY ONE IT'S A
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE PROP
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SUPPORT. TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE OR VERSE
AND. BRING THEM FORWARD
INDIVIDUAL ASSISTANCE SUPPORT OF
S. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX.
THANK YOU AGAIN AT ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE'LL GO TO LINE FORTY
NINE. I'M NOT TOWN CENTER MAIL I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU. APRIL AND CURRENTLY NONE
FOR LEARNING QUEUE OKAY THIS
FALL THE SAME PROCEDURE FOR THE
OPPOSITION I SEE THE MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC HEARING ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SIX A MDERATE IF YOU PLEASE GO
TO THE THOSE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAITING ON OUR- A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICES WHO.
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE. PROMPT THEM
INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU PLEASE
PRESS ONE ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY NINE IN Q. SCHOOLS
PUBLIC CAMPAIGN FOR TWO DAYS
WITHOUT OBJECTION- S. B.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX IS MOVE THE
SUSPENSE FILE SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY TWO BY CENTER STERN IS
FILLED WITH LIQUOR MANSLAUGHTER
SPEEDING AND RECKLESS DRIVING
WHICH IS A SUSPENSE CABINET THE
AUTHORS WE PRESENTATION TO MOVE
RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
FOR ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT AS YOU KNOW MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. HEARING ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SO MODERATOR
LET'S. MOVED TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WAY TO TEST FIVE YEAR
TELECONFERENCE. IF YOU'LL PLEASE
PROP THOSE. WHEN TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FOURTEEN SEVENTY
TWO ON FOLLICULAR MANSLAUGHTER.
THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY NONE IN
Q. I WAS FOR THE SAME PROCEDURE
PROPOSITIONS IN A MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC HEARING ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO MODERATE IF YOU
PLEASE. GO TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
SERVICES MEMBERS OF PUBLIC
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
THE S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO
EMPLOYEES PROP THEM INDIVIDUALLY
. THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND HER
CLEANING Q. AS CLOSE PUBLIC
HEARING BRING BACK TO DAIS
WITHOUT OBJECTION. S. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO IS MOVED TO
SUSPENSE FILE OKAY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC LISO CANYON IS UP
THIS IS S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX NATURAL GAS LEASE SO CANYON
NATURAL GAS STORAGE FACILITY
RELIABILITY IS A SUSPENSE
KENNETH YOU AUTHORS WE
PRESENTATION SO WE MOVE RIGHT TO
THE PUBLIC. TESTIMONY AND ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I
SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
SO MODERATOR. WITHOUT FURTHER
ADO PLEASE PROP MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHICH IN A TEST FIVE YEAR
TELECONFERENCE OVERS AND PROMPT
THEM INDIVIDUALLY IN SUPPORT. OF
SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX. THANK
YOU PLEASE. ONE AT THIS TIME TO
SUPPORT. IF A MOMENT THANK YOU
UP HERE WILL GO FIRST TO LINE
ONE THIRTY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS
PATTY CLICK ON ON THE L. A.
COUNTY- USUALLY STEADY AT FIVE
THREE GROUP IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT LINE. ONE TWENTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON BECAUSE THE
LINE HE ALSO WITH THE COMMUNITY
VISORED IN STRONG SUPPORT ALONG
WITH EVERY SINGLE ELECTED
OFFICIAL THE CLOSURE OF THE
LEASE SO SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX
PROVIDES EQUITABLE PATH TO DO SO
THANK YOU. BOTH HEADLINERS. NINE
I'M NOT CONSCIOUS KARAMANLI
STRONG SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU BILL ARE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LINE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LAURA ROSENBERGER HOT
HYDER I SHOULD POINT AT. THIS
BILL. ONE FOUR EIGHT SIX THANK
YOU. LINE. NINETY SIX. FULL
STORY SUPPORTED ACTION TO CLOSE
THE LEASE OKAY. BE YOUR GAS
STORE FEATURE. THANK YOU NEXT
LINE. ONE ONE SIX. WHAT. TWENTY
THREE. YES BUT HEARING WE'RE ON
BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY SOUTH PLAN
LEGISLATIVE ALLIANCE AND THREE
FIFTY SOUTH BAY LOS ANGELES IS
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. IN LINE. FORTY FIVE.
THAT FORTY FIVE YEAH THANK YOU
MY NAME IS MATT COOK ON THE
PRESIDENT AND CO FOUNDER OF DAVE
PORTER RANCH AND CALIFORNIA FIVE
OH ONE SEE THREE- MYSELF AND I
REMEMBER THAT ORDERS FROM YOUR
SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX
THANK YOU NEXT. SIXTY EIGHT. HI
OH MAN I'M FROM JUST GLAD WHERE
A NATIONAL NON BURKE. I HAD THE
WORD FOR MANY SIX YEARS OF SIDE
. EMERGED WHERE SALAMAT AND THE
PRIVATE SECTOR PROTECT PEOPLE
FROM TOXIC I'M- AND THE WHAT
WHEN INITIALLY REPORTED AS A
SMALL LEAK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AT
THE LEAST SO CANYON NATURAL GAS
STORAGE FACILITY AND AN OVER
SIXTY YEAR OLD INVOLVED AND OUT
TO BE THE LARGEST- TOXIC GAS
WHILE OUT IN THE US. AND TODAY
WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH
RESIDENTS WHO LIVE NEAR THE
FACILITY MANY OF WHOM HAVE
SUFFERED AND CONTINUE TO SUFFER
FROM A NOSE BLEED THERE'S A NET
RESPIRATORY PROBLEMS AND CANCER
THE OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY IS
INHERENTLY TOXIC LEAKS OR
EMISSIONS OF ALL RIGHT AND WE'RE
YEARS YOU'VE GONE FORTUNATELY
WERE IN THE MEETING TO SECTION
OF THIS TESTIMONY SO I HAVE TO.
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT LINE OF
ACTION THANK YOU BLANK YOUR LINE
28% HI MY NAME IS ROSE VAN
WAITED IN THOUSAND OAKS CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CAN A HOPE
CLINIC COALITION WE URGE A YES
VOTE ON SB ONE FOUR EIGHT SIX TO
CLOSE POLICE. IN CAMDEN THANK
YOU. AND LINE THIRTY SO. HI MY
NAME IS TERRIO IN AS IN A RED OF
COURSE SEVENTEEN ON THE PARENT
OF A MINOR PLEASE VOTE YES ON
BILL FOR EIGHTY THANK YOU. LINE
NINETY THREE. HI NAME IS EVELYN
FROM LOS AND I'M BURKE MANY OF
OUR AND YOU AND WE STRONG
DEPLORE AT PEOPLE SIX. LINE
THIRTY FIVE. HELLO MY NAME CALL
NUMBER PRESENTING GLAND INVITE
COALITION THE FAMILY OR YOU HE-
IT'S NINETY NINE GOOD TO HEAR
FROM YOU. HI AS JEFF IN INCOME
FROM LESS THAN FAMILY WOULD
WATER WATCH. WORK AND. ONE
SIXTY. BOLOGNA CAN YOU HAVE A
BELIEF MONACO LYON IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATOR EXPERIENCE
BUILT THE SECOND LISA CANYON AND
KEEP OUR FAMILY AND CHILDREN SAY
. LINE ONE TWO NINE. YES DANIEL
CAMPBELL OF THE INTERFACE
SOLIDARITY NETWORK IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY OF LOS ANGELES
WHERE LISA CANYON IS AN R. FORTY
THREE COMMUNITIES GRAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH US SUPPORT FOR-
SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX WHO SHOT
A LEASABLE DOWN THANK YOU. LINE. ONE TWO. HI THIS IS JENNIFER
TALKED OF CHATSWORTH IN SUPPORT
OF FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX WE SET IT
DOWN. LINE ONE OR TWO. HI MARIA
G. PORTER RANCH RUSH RESIDENTS
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF CLOSURE OF
THE LEAST THE CANYON. LINE ONE
THIRTY ONE. I ONE THIRTY ONE.
THAT MADE. YES I'M LATEST
COMPOST SHERMAN OF THE WEBSITE
COMMUNITY COUNCIL AND WORK WITH
WEBSITES CLEANER COALITION
VENTURA CALIFORNIA. WE SUPPORT
YES ON. FOURTEEN SIX EVENTUALLY
YOU SHUT DOWN A LEASE- CANYON
AND STOP CAUSING US WITH TOXIC
GAS. LINE ONE OH FOUR. HI GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JULIE WAS ON LONG BEACH
REPRESENTING PORTER RANCH
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND I'M
SUPPORTER OF FOOD AND WATER
WATCH WE SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX TO SHUT DOWN THE
LEASE OF CANYON GAS STORAGE
FACILITY SIDE OF THE WORST GAS
FLOWED BLOOD IN US HISTORY AND
IT CONTINUES TO WEAKEN DALY. I
HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS AND FRIENDS
IN THE PORTER RANCH AREA. THANK
YOU ONE FORTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MELANIE
COEN I STRONGLY SUPPORT S. B.
FORTY FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX ON
BEHALF OF FOOD AND WATER WATCH
STATE PORTER RANCH AND THEN
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
RESIDENTS. IN THE VALLEY AND IN
LA THANK YOU THANK YOU LINE ONE
MINUS SEVENTY THREE. WELL GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS MERRY GO
TRUCK LINE I'M WITH PROTECT PLAN
NOW NEAR THE MARINA DEL REY SO
CAL GAS STORAGE FACILITIES ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU. LINE ONE
FORTY EIGHT. HELLO MY NAME IS
ALEX AUSTIN WITH C. PORTER RANCH
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX THANKS. LINE
ONE FORTY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS
JANE FOWLER- AND WITH THE LEAST
AMOUNT THE LION AND I URGE YOU
TO PLEASE PROTECT MY COMMUNITY
WE ARE SUFFERING WITH DAILY
LEAKS THANK YOU AND- THE PORT.
AND THEN FOR THEIR QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THIS
SUPPORT ON SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX WILL NOW OPEN UP FOR
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX SEEING NO ONE COME TO
THE MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION. PLEASE
PRESS ONE DIRECTOR FINE. AND
WITH AN OPEN LINE WELL GIVE ME
JUST A MONTH OR WITHOUT WRITERS
HERE.
ONE ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON SHANE
GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE UTILITY
WORKERS UNION OF AMERICA AND THE
WORK FORCE AND LISA CANYON. IN
OPPOSITION. LINE ONE OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAL'S WITH SO
CAL GAS IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX FOR POLICY
AND FISCAL REASONS AND STAFF AND
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR ANALYSIS. LINE ONE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
THIRTY SIX. AND BRACKETING IN
RESPONSE FROM ONE THIRTY SIX AND
NINE PER QUEUE ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
VESTBY FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX
SYNCING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT BILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE
ON THE S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY ONE
BY SENATOR BRADFORD ON CANNABIS
TAXES. IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
RIGHT HERE ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED COMMA. HILL AGAINST
SENATORS. MY NAME IS TACK ALLEN
AND THE LEGISLATIVE CHAIR FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT PARTY
BLACK CAUCUS AND WE ARE SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL WTH THE EMPHASIS
ON AMENDMENTS AT EQUITY
LANGUAGE. THANK YOU. SEE NO ONE
ELSE IN THIS ROOM ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE. PRESS ONE
DIRECTORS FIND. AND CURRENTLY
NOT A CUE ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF SB TWELVE EIGHTY
ONE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO TWELVE EIGHTY
ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND CURRENTLY NOBODY
AQ ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION OF US BE TWELVE
EIGHTY ONE AND WITHOUT ANY
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWELVE EIGHTY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB TWELVE
NINETY THREE BY SENATOR BRADFORD
ON INCOME TAXATION CREDITS.
CANNABIS EQUITY APPLICATIONS AND
LICENSES WE WILL GO RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWELVE NINETY THREE COME ON
UP. THE CITY P. BLACK CAUCUS
SUPPORTS THIS BILL AND ELECTED
EXPAND DISCUSSION ON THE
SPECIFICITY OF THE EQUITY
DEFINITION. DUE TO THE ISSUES
THAT WE'RE HAVING WITH OUR LA
TRIALS. ON THE OF IT THE EQUITY
DEFINITION IS NOT NARROW DOWN
ENOUGH AND THERE A LOT OF
LOOPHOLES BEING EXPLOITED WHERE
THE COMMUNITY THAT SHOULD BE
SERVICED. BY THIS EQUITY PROGRAM
THAT'S BEING OFFERED ARE
ACTUALLY BEING SHUT OUT OF THE
PROGRAM STILL- IN REFINING THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF PROJECT IN
PLACE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT SEE NO ONE ELSE IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT MODERATOR WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE. OF S. B.
TWELVE NINETY THREE SUPPORT.
HE'S PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
CURRENTLY NOBODY AND CUTE ALL
RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK FOR
OPPOSITION- AND THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM A POST- WILL GO
MODERATOR ANYBODY ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO TWELVE NINETY
THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND CURRENTLY NOBODY
IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF S. B.
TWELVE NINETY THREE THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION TWELVE NINETY
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE
ON S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE
BRADFORD ON VEHICLE TRAFFIC
STOPS IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. INSUPPORT IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE MODERATE FOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF. THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE. PRESS
ONE THERE AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY MANY CUTE ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION
OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE IS
THERE ANYONE IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE OPPOSE
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED TO. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AFTER FIVE TO OPPOSE. IT
CURRENTLY LEARNING QUEUE ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION AND WE HAVE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON THE S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR NEWMAN-
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE HYDROGEN
FUELING STATIONS. IT'S A
SUSPENSE CABINET THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN UP PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AND FROM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THERE'S NOBODY HERE.
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
IN SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE. THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE GO
FIRST TO THE LINE FORTY NINE. MY
NAME IS DONNA THOMPSON IN CARMEL
AND I SUPPORT THE BILL. THIRTEEN
TWENTY NINE. IF YOU'VE GOT ONE
MORE HERE GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT. AND WE CAN OPEN LINE THIRTY
EIGHT. THIRTY EIGHT. HI MACNIDER
ON WE HAVE TO BEAR WITH YOU IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE. ANCHORMAN AND Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL COME BACK FOR OPPOSITION
OF THIRTEEN TWENTY NINE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED
MODERATORS ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED THE THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE DIRECTORS
TIME. CURRENTLY NINE Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE AND THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES SO THAT
OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
NINE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE
ON SB THIRTEEN FORTY BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG ON PROPERTY TAXATION
NEW CONSTRUCTION ACTIVE SOLAR
ENERGY SYSTEMS AND NON QUALIFIED
ACTIVE SOLAR- IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN
FORTY. THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN FORTY. PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE CAN OPEN
LINE THIRTY EIGHT IS GO AHEAD.
VICTIMS ALSO THANK YOU I WILL
TRY THIS AGAIN THEY'RE BACK HERE
. THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI MACNIDER ON BEHALF OF SOME
POWER IN SUPPORT OF SB. THIRTEEN
FORTY. AND CURRENTLY NONE
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
COME BACK TO THIS ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION AT THIRTEEN FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY IN THE ROOM
OPPOSED. MODERATORS ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB
THIRTEEN FORTY. PLEASE PRESS ONE
DIRECTORS TIME. AND CURRENTLY
NONE IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION AT
THIRTEEN FORTY SINGLE QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THIRTEEN FORTY WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE WE HAVE OUR FINAL
BILL OF THE DAY WHICH IS SB
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE BY SENATOR
LEYVA ON PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RETIREMENT IN CHARTER SCHOOLS
IT'S A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION. WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT I
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THERE'S
NOBODY HERE WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINE MODERATOR FOR SUPPORT
OF S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY THREE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONE MOMENT HERE.
AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO. AN OPEN
LINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MERION ASHLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN FORTY THREE THANK
YOU. ANCHORMAN FURTHER IN Q. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE OPPOSITION AT
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM LOTTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED
TO THIRTEEN FORTY THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE CORRECTIVE TIME. AND
WE CAN OPEN LINE EIGHTY NINE.
MISTER KERR THIS IS BOB NAYLOR
PERHAPS YOUR VERY LAST CALLER
REPRESENTING FEELS THAT IN
COMPANY THAT'S HOWARD ELEMENTS
IN JUNIOR AND ORANGE COUNTY
POLITICOS STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE. CURRENTLY NINE
FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE AND SEEING
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE GOES TO
SUSPENSE WE HAVE NOTHING ON CALL
WE'VE GONE THROUGH EVERY BILL
PLACE THE MALL ON THE SUSPENSE
CALENDAR- SO WE INCLUDED OUR
AGENDA OBVIOUSLY THURSDAY IS THE
DAY WHERE WE DEAL WITH. THE
SUSPENSE CALENDAR SO ALL OF YOU
TUNE IN THURSDAY AFTER SESSION
THANK 
PARTICIPATING IN OUR TESTIMONY
IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
FOR ANY REASON PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE INCLUDE EVERYONE IN
THE PUBLIC RECORD. THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND
THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE ELSE MY
COLLEAGUES FOR HELPING US GET
THROUGH THE SENATE- AGENDA THESE
LAST COUPLE WEEKS AND WITH THAT
WE'LL SEE YOU ON THURSDAY SO
WE'RE ADJOURNED FOR TODAY. YOU.